due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the coven
19 pandemic in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing on all bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporary list in
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and
selected legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporariously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contemporary
listed listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600
or email hcs at
ledge.state.nh.u
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and rescheduled please note that all
votes that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
with each member states their presence
please let also state whether there's
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the
right to know law okay
keith are you there i'm here all right
you're on
all right representative hunt i am here
and i am alone
representative patusek i am here i am
upstairs
in my room and my wife is downstairs
osborne
representative amman i'm here and i'm
alone
representative abramson
abramson
uh
[Music]
johnson here in the llb
alone representative terry
president alone in the room
representative bartlett
here alone in my room
representative abel uh present
and uh my wife is here for the next
about five minutes and then leaving
representative herbert
representative van houghton i'm here and
i'm alone
representative fargo i'm karen i'm alone
representative weston here and alone
representative bill you here home alone
representative burroughs i'm here i'm
alone in this office
representative mcelroy
representative bakalir
okay that's the role mr chair we have
looks like 15
present
well about the public hearing on uh
senate bill 18
and is uh senator birdsall is she there
i am here can you hear me oh yes
they're already on how did you do that
somebody promoted me
all right thank you pam okay
so good morning and welcome to the
health commerce committee good morning
mr chair good morning committee
for the record my name is regina
birdsell i'm the state senator for
district 19 which encompasses the town
of derry hampstead and windham
and i am the prime sponsor of senate
bill
18 and senate senate bill 18
um allows the tasting
of um distilleries to come to farmer's
markets
and they limit the amount to half an
ounce per
label per person
it just adds to the rsa
what the breweries and the
wineries are able to do
and it's pretty much targeted for
only uh incubator distilleries
in in the state and i think you'll hear
from a number of the
distilleries hopefully um i know the one
from derry
i believe he should be on the line andy
day
and it limits the um
distilleries to only i think
distilleries that have that um
have 10 000 bottles
so that they per year so that they can
um keep it an incubator process
and in the senate uh senate hearing
uh the the uh
liquor commission was in full support
of the legislation
and i don't know if um
if you have any questions i'll be glad
to take any
okay do we have questions from the
committee we are somewhat familiar with
this issue since
music has a similar bill
we might not be too much uh questions on
this issue
and let's say representative mcclear
uh oh you're he's in the wrong place
okay so i'm gonna
i'm gonna move promote the panelists
okay so you have a question or you just
have your hand up for me to promote you
chris
uh okay now i have another
so no no questions okay now i have
another question
from julie h i'm not sure who julie h is
i think that's representative herbert oh
and so we need to um yeah apparently
there must have been a problem getting
people signed in
and we should be sure that they are
included in the
role um account call right
so keith i'm adding them though thank
you thank you
okay so is that you chris are you is
that your wife's name julie
he's muted there he's unmuted okay yeah
i didn't show up when i first came in so
i'm trying to get squared away here
okay no problem you're all you're you're
interested
same thing happened to me i was i was on
but you couldn't see me
right well i because you came in
whatever you logged in at you didn't log
in on the
thing that they send you like an hour
ago or send you before
if you if you came in a different way
like say from the calendar then you're
coming in as an attendee rather than as
a panelist
so then i just have to promote you know
okay
see no questions for the senator uh
guess we're all says thank you very much
thank you
okay uh now did anybody else wanna speak
on this
issue let's
pull my sheets up here sorry
um aiden moore had had registered
okay all right so i will uh he's already
in the panel
he's already up from real you're way
ahead of me today well i was
i was just trying to help thank you i
appreciate it
nothing new there mr chair okay attorney
moore um
from the local commission you want to
speak to this bill
uh thank you mr chairman can you hear me
okay yes we can
thank you uh good morning committee
members uh you've heard from senator
burcell
i really am here to see if there are any
technical questions you might have
um on this bill and if not
i'd be happy to take any questions at
any point in time during the day
okay so i guess just to make sure so
this is the one that
you guys amended in the senate and
everything in this bill is now the way
you
think it's uh appropriate uh yes we
we worked with uh senator birdsell to
uh craft some of the amended language or
the some of the language that you see
to limit it to small businesses that are
operating solely within the state and in
an attempt to make sure that this
is an effort to promote new hampshire
businesses and
really not become a platform for larger
uh
distilleries from out of state to come
in to
participate good great uh
representative abel has a question for
you
yes thank you could you just quickly
review
for us how issues
like checking identification to make
sure
someone is uh of legal age and so forth
how how that would be is covered in the
bill
excuse me thank you representative for
your question um
you can see in the language that you
have above
excuse me lines i believe 2 through
10 describe the the
process and limitations farmers markets
are
a process that is controlled locally
so when a distiller is going to
participate whether it's a distillery or
a winery or a beverage manufacturer
they need to register and pay whatever
fees are going to be
necessary at the local level follow
whatever rules
that exist at the local level for
placement et cetera hours of
operation and then it will be incumbent
upon any of the licensees
who are participating the umbrella that
exists
over this entire process is rsa1795
which is a statute that prohibits
alcohol from being
provided or sold to an intoxicated
person or to a person under
21. so any of the businesses that are
licensed by the commission
would need to adhere to that
statutory guideline at all times of
their operation
so i'm not sure if that answers your
question sir
okay representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um thank you for
coming to see us um
mr moore um mine is a similar question
to
uh representative abel's i mean it was
kind of in light of
the hearing that we had yesterday and
kind of going over enforcement issues
so that kind of um
made me a little bit more informed
although
small small amount um again
if we're going back to this is a change
from beer and wine to hard liquor
um and i i see that that it's a smaller
amount
that the distillers would be able to
offer a half an ounce per label
are you aware of any of these small
distilleries that have more than one
label
thank you for your question
representative i can't tell you for
certain
exactly uh how many distilleries have
more than one label
and i would suggest that probably if a
distillery were going to participate
they'd probably want to bring
their entire line of products so if they
were to produce a
whiskey or a rum or a vodka or a gin
most likely they would want to be
bringing those products
along that that being said
i think there's uh certainly a concern
that uh farmers markets don't end
turn into a happy hour where you get to
just kind of work your way down the line
and drink and drink and drink
uh the half ounce again where we look at
some of the sizes based upon the alcohol
content uh of the products
so a half ounce spirits rather
if 80 proof or made up of 40 alcohol by
volume
and so therefore the decision to confine
it to a smaller amount is
is really to try to
provide the consumer with an opportunity
to taste but yet
not such a quantity that
it would be something that they could
become intoxicated on solely
now if if a business that's at a farmers
market
has multiple labels and just wants to
start serving them
most likely they're going to charge for
them to sample it
and hopefully the
pricing of it would be such that it
wouldn't be an encouragement for the
for the person to over consume and as i
mentioned to
representative abel governing and
overseeing this entire process would be
rsa1795
which would uh make it unlawful for the
licensee to
serve a person to the point of
intoxication
ask another question for the question in
clara thanks very much
um so i've been to the maiden new
hampshire
expo and is is
a mead considered a distilled product
uh no needs are kind of in a world of
their own
um their
your committee has over the years taken
up many definitional changes and
percentages of alcohol by volume
so within the definition of a beverage
meat is kind of defined so it's it's
it certainly is an alcoholic beverage
and
based upon its classification um
would be eligible to be brought to a
farmer's market
for tasting right and the answer would
be it's be a wine
poor okay so that's a wine and we know
that
moonlight meadery which i happen to like
very much um
has a lot of meads so they can have all
those different
they already can have all the different
tasting of all the different meads
yes ma'am subject to whatever the limit
on
wine is and then if tamworth distillery
comes down
of course i don't know how many bottles
they do per year is that considered an
incubator distillery
well we would we would use that um i
can't tell you for exactly exactly what
their production is annually
um and i think what we'll probably do if
this were to become law
is when a business is
we would notify these distilleries uh
based upon what production levels they
have reported
uh if they're eligible to participate in
the farmers markets or not
okay so that would be up to the liquor
commission to notify
the distilleries we we would obviously
look at their figures they're the ones
who report to us their production
so we we would make sure that they knew
of the law change
probably the association is going to
inform the members of
any law change anyway but we would
certainly work with that industry to
make sure that they understand
what the limitations are uh on this uh
it should have become law
thank you very much and just so uh
everybody knows so a half an ounce is
actually a
third of a shot the shot is actually an
ounce and a half
so it would be you would have to take
three samples before you had a shot
or an alcohol let him do it for me but
but you know what martini has like three
in it
you couldn't make that taste good enough
for me
okay any other questions for uh attorney
moore
saying none we thank you very much uh
all right i have nobody else signed up
so i oh i do say hand raised
uh and it's andy day
from dory distilling good morning
andy
can you hear me yes we can excellent
thank you
um thank you chairman uh thank you
committee for being here my name is andy
day
uh i own dware distilling uh in downtown
derry
um i appreciate you guys being here
today and hearing this
um senator bridzel has worked with us in
the past and
really done a lot of good things and i
feel like this is uh the next step
in um helping small business uh we would
be one of these uh incubator
distilleries uh small production and
just trying to get our name out there
some of these questions actually came up
in the senate hearing
and i wanted to address that we are a
business
and we take alcohol very seriously
and want people to have a safe
experience with it
we also don't want to give away
everything so i do have
probably 20 different products i would
probably select
a handful of those that i would want to
display at the farmer's market
and then very much like i do in my
tasting room when someone comes in and
says oh well
what do you have my question to them is
well what do you like
because i don't want to taste somebody
through everything that i have
i would rather narrow down their choices
and give them a couple of samples and
see what they like because at the end of
the day
i want to make that sale so i will also
say that
distilleries wineries and breweries tend
to work together collectively to make
sure that everyone has a safe experience
so when it comes to things like iding um
over
serving i just monitoring people's
alcohol intake
will kind of signal to each other and
communicate
you know this this person probably
doesn't need anything else
and just kind of work as a team so we're
we're very excited about this
i would very much like to see this bill
pass it would be extremely helpful for
us
i appreciate your time
okay uh representative patrick has a
question if you're willing to entertain
one
uh thank you mr chair
would you believe that as a
board of directors member of the dairy
farmers market
uh i've worked with uh andy day
on other bills and uh we're very strict
and stringent
on who gets to taste where they get the
taste
we have uh areas marked out according to
the uh state statutes
and uh i'm looking forward to working
with him on this bill also would you
believe
yeah that means you can't you don't have
to answer the question andy but
if you want to say something nice about
the very farmer's market you can do that
okay uh oh i do have another hand up
uh christopher burke
thank you very much andy
good morning can you hear me okay
hi a quick introduction i'm christopher
burke my wife and i own
cathedral alleged distillery in north
conway new hampshire
we are i believe the newest distillery
in new hampshire we opened in december
so we are certainly in that incubator
phase
we also have the distinction of being
new hampshire's first certified organic
distillery
worked very closely with the the ag
department to get that certification
and certainly would welcome an
opportunity to meet people at farmer's
markets who value
or prioritize fresh and organic
ingredients in their products
so we certainly encourage support of
this bill
great thank you thank you very much
okay uh you know questions
uh all right is uh i have no more hands
up so
i guess we're gonna ready to close this
hearing unless somebody else has
something else they want to add
uh seeing none um we had
uh 10 supporters and one person was
opposed
much uh sure oh it was uh
okay fry yeah of course from new futures
so that's great uh so being that uh we
will close the public hearing on senate
bill 18.
and uh next is
so we're where are we scheduled so we're
right i didn't take this one tight right
then right yeah
we're on time we're we're going to build
14 yeah
okay so we'll open up the public hearing
on
and um
i believe lou told me he wasn't was this
the one that lou wasn't going to be able
to attend
well he's in the attendees there he is
okay
so that was a different bill yeah that's
right that was the trust bill okay so
um senator d'alessandro i'm promoting
you up to
a panelist and you can introduce the
bill
okay you're on lube you have to just uh
unmute yourself
uh thank you mr chairman uh for the
record
i'm senator lou d'alessandro i represent
district 20
manchester awards 3 4 10 11 of the town
of goffstown
come before you as the prime sponsor of
senate bill 14.
uh last session this bill this bill
passed the senate however it was
uh it wasn't included in an anonymous
bill when it went across
this bill was refiled at the request of
the new hampshire liquor commission
a key component of state revenues is the
profits produced
by the sale of of liquor this bill will
give the commission the ability to
directly ship liquor
in turn this would allow the commission
to add another arrow
in there in their equivalent to promote
the sale of spirits and minds throughout
the state
and nationally uh under chairman
walker's leadership
the commission has has built many new
physical locations
it created an online presence
this this allows
this allows them to expand those these
opportunities
[Music]
every time we put a budget together we
depend upon the revenues from the liquor
commission
uh to put uh our budget in a positive
in a positive mode and this gives the
commission another opportunity
uh it's it's tool kit uh
to promote itself and to add additional
revenues to the state of new hampshire
with that mr chairman i thank you very
much for the opportunity to appear
before you
uh i'm sure people are here from the
commission who could give you
a much more extended presentation
but it's always an honor to appear
before this committee uh representative
hunt
and uh distinguished members of the
committee great to see you early
in the morning everyone looks bright and
cheerful and uh
thank you so much for that it's a great
american day
representative and uh with that i hope
that you'll
pass this on and we'll do great things
thank you
uh thank you uh senator dallas andrew
it's always a pleasure to have you in
front of commerce
uh so do anybody have any particular
questions so uh
i guess just to reaffirm this language
is exactly the same like
we passed yes yes
we do have a question representative
weston has a question
uh thank you for taking my question and
thank you senator d'alessandro for
coming to testify for us
i want the question on the amendment uh
is that something that you could address
uh i haven't
i haven't i don't have the ability to be
before we
could i could i ask the question and and
it looks as though maybe uh
representative patuck might be able to
answer it
um my question on the amendment
is that um we have that that
pesky word shell in there and
i know that there are some small
retailers that might
be interested in and um selling these
products but are would a small
uh be required to um
apply for a direct shipper permit they
may have no interest in
shipping their product
first of all thank you so much uh
representative for the for the for the
query
uh i don't have the amendment in my
original bill it said may register
so i i haven't see i haven't seen the i
have
i don't have the amendment before me i
apologize for that
i think someone from the commission
might be able to address that question
right physically and so they're they're
there
i think i think they're in the queue
aren't they representative that's guy
attorney morrison available so uh uh
representing western u.s
are you referring to representative
lang's amendment that we got was floated
around yes i am and maybe i was
premature in asking the question
so the senator might be totally unaware
that that that amendment is floating
around
okay i understand thank you oh so but um
just so you know
attorney uh senator um what the
what it is is uh reference to um
that allowing in-state beverage
manufacturers
uh or wineries or and soldiers to be
able to direct ship
currently uh the only people who can
direct ship uh
into new hampshire is from out of state
and that is what the
uh the amendment is about so it's
it is a definitely totally different
issue is that what you wanted to talk
about
between uh john mentioned yes mr
chairman
um uh representative lang asked me to
introduce the uh
the amendment uh and okay
well okay
did he go to legislative services and
actually have an amendment drawn up
uh yes it was distributed um
okay because i saw the language i saw
the emails about it but i didn't know
that it was an actual right
uh i don't know if ms smarling
distributed it to the
committee but i i i was i was on a
young yet yeah i was sent a copy with
the
unapproved
uh this weekend and uh and i think we
should copy the senator on this too
so we will certainly uh so we'll let you
we'll just send you a copy of the
amendment yeah thank you
thank you very much okay so we have any
other uh questions for
senator d'alessandro seeing none or i
assume that hand okay say none
uh thank you very much senator thank you
uh
uh aidan you're you're still up so now
uh attorney moore from the liquor
commission can
uh respond to the underlying bill and i
guess uh you should respond to
the amendment thank you mr chairman
uh thank you senator d'alessandro um
representatives the senate bill 14 gives
the commission
the authority to register trade names
with the secretary of state
and to operate as a direct shipper of
liquor and wines
in this and other jurisdictions and as
the senator mentioned
excuse me this this bill is very
important to the commission
as we try to maintain our
competitiveness
with other states to give us the
opportunity
as the markets open across the country
to register as a direct shipper
in other states and to pursue the
opportunity to
ship into those states from new
hampshire as well as the ability
to work within the state of new
hampshire and serve customer needs
for the purposes of products that the
commission sells
and to possibly ship those working with
the new hampshire manufacturers to
develop a strategy that would
make delivery an important part of what
the commission does in the way of
producing revenue for the general fund
and i'd be happy to take any questions
on the
underlying bill representative if you
if there are any okay um
i do not s there's any questions on the
underlying bill
um and i i i'm not sure that you have
seen this amendment then i assume
i i have seen a draft of something
floating around
if that is in fact what the amendment is
i can probably give you some information
on it if you'd like
yeah so uh the language of yeah just
adding including in the state of new
hampshire
uh so who is eligible to take advantage
of the direct shipping
license um
procedurally sir does that need to be as
it has it been officially introduced yet
evidently it just did now now
i would say that uh um
normally if something like this you know
i i the chair would have to rule on
tremaineness
and and then decide whether that
uh we would need to hold a separate
hearing on germainus or not
at this moment i'm i'm going to hold off
on making that decision
so because i just need to uh know
understand the consequences
of adding this this in because it is
direct shipping
so it is the direct shipping statute so
it's certainly germaine enough in terms
of the actual rsa
but in terms of the intent the
difference between between
a licensee and that this
underlying bill is just the commission
but so i guess uh how do you
how do you feel about uh in-state
producers being able to direct ship to
people in new hampshire
well thank you sir for your question um
the the if if i understand the amendment
which would uh amend
rsa 178 colon 27
adding in the phrase including the state
of new hampshire
as you know mr chairman and for the
member benefit of the committee members
who are not around
at that time direct shipping was created
with largely with the legislation
introduced by representative hunt
to allow businesses
located outside of the state of new
hampshire
to register with the state of new
and to ship their products into the
state
to consumers uh who wish to purchase
products that might not be available
within the state
uh that has been uh in place for some
time
and the change that's
that is being proposed would now
appear to extend
the direct shipper permit
process to every licensee
who is licensed within the state of new
hampshire uh
it speaks to um including the state of
excu
let me if i could just step back for
just a moment
and i'd like to kind of parse through
the words here with you a bit
notwithstanding any other provision of
law to the contrary any person currently
licensed in its state of domicile
including the state of new hampshire as
a wine manufacturer
beverage manufacturer importer
wholesaler or retailer may apply for a
direct shipper permit from the
commission
that's pretty broad and it looks like
everybody except a rectifier to me
well it's it it doesn't it doesn't have
rec it doesn't have rectifiers
right it doesn't have nano brewers
um it speaks to
terms such as the use of the word
importer
the word importer does not appear in
title 13.
it presents a challenge to
us if this were to pass as written
to determine an importer is someone who
is licensed maybe in
an out-of-state uh facility
or the state of the business rather
wholesalers are we speaking about
hampshire wholesalers because if so then
i think they would need to be referred
to
uh properly as as to who they are
within our statutes so that they be can
be correctly identified
by including these um
businesses within the direct direct
shipper fee
excuse me direct shippers statute if you
are a wine manufacturer within the state
of new hampshire
and you want to do this you're going to
have to pay a fee of 100
because that's what's in the statute
that's what the fee is for wine
manufacturers
if you're an importer or a retailer
and retailers are not defined either
because
we i think we all presume we know what a
retailer is but for the purposes of
interpreting the statute and applying
the statute we would probably want
additional clarity as to
who would be in that class under the
current
fee requirements a retailer
now that could be on premise could be
off-premise
we don't really know it could be
restaurants
could be anybody they would have to pay
a fee of five hundred dollars
to obtain this uh and as as
why would their fee be higher that's
just the fee schedule that the
legislature has
put in place in in for the direct
shipping in other words
the way i read this is that you're
getting a direct shipping license
over and above whatever license you
already have correct
right now the direct license we don't we
don't vary that that license fee based
upon the type of
this is this is this is the fee these
are the fees that are applied
to businesses who apply for direct
shippers permit to ship
into the state by including this
language
and by making in my opinion by making
this statutory provision applicable to
in-state businesses
you don't relieve them of the fee
requirements
you essentially expose them to the fee
requirements right
you also expose them to the limitations
on the quantities that they can ship
and go ahead sir i'm sorry that's fine
um so by including them here
this um
it certainly can be done it could i was
i would think it would need further
clarification
within the definition of eligibility for
178.27 so that the commission could
apply it
clearly um i'm not sure mr chairman if
it's
appropriate at this time to mention that
there is another bill
um senate bill 125 which has yet to
appear before your committee
in which this issue is addressed from a
product from a perspective
of intra state shipment a separate and
distinct
approach to the shipment
of alcohol within the state
by new hampshire licensees so
we have that 125 is is also a direct
shipping bill
also it has a piece of that heard a lot
of stories about 125 so i don't know
what's in it
it has it has a piece of that in it a
piece in it okay and
and within that um there would be no
charge
for licensure current licensee for a
current license in new hampshire
to obtain a direct shipment so so you're
suggesting that
that um maybe this amendment the problem
with this amendment is that there's
gonna be an action
added fee to it but that if uh in 125
um everyone would still be able does
that include rectifiers and nanos and
it does not um it would again
subject to whoever drafted the amendment
uh and who they wanted to include
if you're looking for the broadest
possible
application then i think the eligibility
pieces in both this bill uh senate bill
14 as amended
with rsa 178 27
and senate bill
and the other senate bill 125 would also
need to be
examined to make sure that the
definitions
were broad enough to include the class
of licensees that you would like to see
eligible to participate okay
all right well the good news is we have
plenty of time to figure that out before
this bill has these bills have to be out
of
committee we do have a couple of hands
up um
we'll start uh with uh
representative weston thank you mr chair
um
i just wanted to mention that when uh mr
moore
uh read the amendment he did say
that the he did use the word may
apply for a direct ship or permit but
this amendment does say
shell which in my mind
means that they would be required to do
it whether they needed to or not
so i know there's a lot of problems here
and that it sounds like we'll be
working on this anyway but i was just
curious that
that the way it was read was different
from what i have on my
clearly the shall the child must be in
the statue that that's
chow was already in the statute um
and i think that it it was
really is someone who wrote this bill
wrote the lie
i would say is the show was saying that
if you wanted to ship into new hampshire
you shall get a direct shipping license
that was what the challenge meant not
that you had to get a license
whether you wanted to or not it says
only if you wanted to
ship into the state of new hampshire
that's what that shell means
okay thank you but i agree with you that
it obviously we would not want to
force someone to get a license they
don't want better pay for it
representative herbert um thank you
chairman hunt um all i'm interested in
is some direction as to number one
uh how much time and then what are we
going to do in order to get a finished
product uh uh successfully
uh made i don't have any clue
i i mean obviously there's sounded like
a half a dozen to a dozen
uh things that uh attorney
moore uh pointed out as problematic
so um and we have another bill
which is senate bill and i'm i'm i'm
basically very confused so i
would appreciate it if the chairman uh
chairman hunt could uh kind of lay out a
road map
uh as to how we're going to uh
get this bill in shape for a vote
well obviously i originally had hoped to
have senate bill 125 today but
unfortunately
it didn't didn't get to us so yet
so um and for whatever reason so i don't
know if it was
you know what was the issues going on in
the senate just did the senate when did
senate bill 125 actually pass the senate
yet
turn anymore i believe it has sir okay
so um but we'll schedule that hearing
and then basically
you know we'll um i i as much as i
don't want to do subcommittees per se um
i guess we would uh you know need to do
a
straw poll see how everybody feels i
would assume that
everyone here is okay with allowing new
hampshire businesses
to take advantage of the direct shipping
laws unless if somebody thinks
differently then you know i think you
you know that that uh
they'll need to voice that opinion um
but that you know that we all would want
them to be able to take advantage of the
law
uh and as long as it's affordable
enforceable and done
right uh and i'm sure they would like to
do it without an extra fee
so um if that's what's in senator 125
that sounds like that might be
the way where it will end up going but
uh in either case we'll have
we'll have both these bills to discuss
um but in terms of when uh
everything has to be out of out of the
committee our deadline is may 27th
so we literally have practically the
whole month of may to
to figure these things out so
mr chairman this is aiden i was
wondering if i could ask you a
procedural question
certainly where the
amendment uh introduced by
representative tusic
is now part of senate
senate bill 14. yes
will they be considered together
and certainly certainly the underlying
bill
is very important to the commission
and i'm not sure uh if you feel
another they need to remain together
yeah yeah
just about voices in the background here
i don't know where that's coming from
somebody needs
okay i would say in my personal opinion
um
if that if drag shipping is in senate
bill 125
my preference would be to take it up in
that bill
that way i don't have to decide whether
there's germain or not
okay in terms of the issue um clearly
uh this this bill is a direct shipping
bill but
it was a it's a bill that is directly
just at
the uh commission and not licensee so i
see representative lang would like to
probably weigh
in here so um i would say on the face of
it
um we would work with them together but
if if
um i could if we can get it worked out
in senate bill 125
then that would be a good thing um i
just know that there are some
people have had concerns about 25 so i
would be concerned
with some of the other issues that are
in that bill and whether that would
also baggage this you know that this
issue would not
happen if it was in that bill so in that
case um then i would want
this issue to be in senate bill 14. so i
guess we i
i want to wait to we do 125 and see
where we are with that bill
um for now i'll let representative lang
testify and then unless
unless you have a specific question to
me or or
you have a question for me yes um just
to clarify the answer that you gave
aidan at this point the two are separate
the amendment and the bill are not
married
the amendment needs to be accepted
before it becomes a part of it so there
is
the underlying bill is still clean as
far as amendments go am i correct
that is correct thank you okay
representative lange
thank you mr chairman thank you
committee i apologize for being late i
was running a little behind this morning
um thank you for letting me testify
again i i brought this amendment um work
with
representative um because again i i was
felt it was important that new hampshire
breweries and and
liquor distributors licensees be uh on
par
with out of state they should not be you
know hindered
uh what out of state people can do and
and in writing it in this
met way one of the things that's
happening now
is that again the liquor commission and
the attorneys
have to align the definitions that are
in this with our new hampshire
statutes to make sure that the licensee
in the other state
qualifies under these definitions are
there a wine manufacturer beverage
manufacturer
and i'll note that the title of uh
senate bill 125
is relative to beverage manufacturers so
they're already making those
determinations as to what licensees fall
into what categories
um again this is a parity bill it just
brings new hampshire
businesses in parity with out of
businesses we should not be hobbling or
hindering
our in-state businesses and giving
preference to out-of-state businesses
um and that is it i will say that 125
does have
a whole lot more to do with you know
defining
beverage manufacturer licenses
quantities of alcohol that they produce
and there's a whole lot more
rather than a direct conversation around
do we want to allow
our new hampshire
uh alcohol licensees to be able to
direct ship with inter
interstate interest state rather than uh
just interstate
um and they should be able my opinion is
they should be allowed to capture new
hampshire market as well as any out of
state market
uh through the direct direct shipping
model and
um and i hope the committee would adopt
this amendment
and uh and and move the bill forward
even if it's flawed with that shell
being misinterpreted
well again i i if i if i understood the
conversation to shall
is that if they want to participate in
direct shipping
uh they shall obtain a license and the
license fee is a hundred dollars it
sounded like
and and i'm okay with that be honest
with you i mean if if if you
want to further amendments bill to to
take that uh
if it's a new hampshire licensee has
already paid for a licensee
uh uh for a license that they the fee
can be waived i'm completely okay with
that
um but again the idea is right now they
can't even participate
um in a meaningful way okay so
we have two different issues one is we
you know we want them to be able to do
this
okay and the question is to be able to
do this
is it what is the best way to do this so
we go look at their
statute and their license and put it in
there
versus putting it in this section which
would mean they would have to pay an
extra fee
so my take would be is they would
probably not want to be in the statute
if we could put it somewhere else so
that they would not have to pay an extra
fee
but i'm not sure that because the
purpose of the fee
is the administrative costs of the
direct shipping program
which one of the things we heard
yesterday was that lba
thinks the commission is dropping the
ball uh because they haven't figured out
how to make sure
that there's no illegal shipments into
the state and that people are doing
everything properly so
there might be some question that the
fee is not enough so this is open for
discussion
either way going that way but i would
tell you representative lang
before you get you know so pushing this
language about why
you know they only a fairness issue um i
introdu i
sponsored this bill over 20 years ago 20
years ago okay and no one
no one in the state of new hampshire is
ever come up to me and say gee we really
would like to be able to direct ship
inside the state and the reason being is
is that the consumer
is now going to have to pay an 8 tax
so i would think that most consumers
would probably try it if
not no santa covered obviously code
changed everything where we weren't
shopping anywhere but the idea that um
you know we don't even have a bottle
bill in the state the idea that now
you're gonna charge
eight percent for that for that very
exclusive whatever product you're buying
beer
i i always thought was a um
a a deterrent from wanting to do
business
that way and that if the product is made
in new hampshire it certainly should be
available to buy an answer
without an eight percent tax added to it
i fully agree mr chairman and and again
i
uh part of this was brought to me by the
industry itself so they're at least
wanting the option and this is the
chapter they were
they they brought to me and said did you
look at this and then i went around and
asked around at some of the uh
i have a brewery right in my in my
community and i went to them and chatted
with them
um and they were they were okay with
that so again
i would tell you that the industry
itself is the ones that brought this
forward because at least they want the
option that they don't have right now
and they're willing to pay for that
option
fair enough okay
any questions for representative lang
okay see man thank you very much uh
oh excuse me representative mcclaire you
have a question i see
you very chris oh no okay not all right
it's gone
uh okay so i have seen no hands up and
attendees
no panelists okay so i guess we've
fully discussed this issue um
and we have four people in support no
opposition to senate bill 14.
and with that oh well i do have a hand
up now
uh kevin daigle uh
i'm gonna promote you kevin
and representing the grocers
and you just have to unmute yourself and
you'll be good kevin
great thank you chairman can you hear me
well yes we can perfect
uh good morning mr chairman members of
the committee
uh for the record my name is kevin
daigle and i am the vice president of
the new hampshire grocers association
representing convenience stores
supermarkets here in the state of new
hampshire
i'll start by saying we have not seen
the amendment
and we were not planning to speak to the
underlying bill
but do want to speak to the amendment
which does not appear to be related to
the bill itself
as you guys have discussed well we might
understand the desire for parity across
all licensees the broadening of the
statute could very likely have some
unintended consequences
including direct impacts and economic
consequences for our retailers
and a significant disruption of new
hampshire's long-standing three-tiered
system
a system we fully support and believes
works well um
we're not comfortable making this change
until it can be thoroughly vetted
but that's something it says you guys
are looking at doing
um and we'd urge the committee at this
stage to defer any action on the
amendment until there's a better
understanding of its intent
ramifications thank you
um so kevin i'm glad you're here um
because
my my question to you is um
given covet i i've been using instant
cart
for doing my grocery shopping and i know
that both
hannaford and market baskets are listed
there um
and don't don't can i buy beer through
my
instacart and from from a grocer i
believe you can
um it's part of their um license as
is um so they just need to be able to
have that license with them if they're
doing to home delivery
or whatnot and then making sure the
delivery driver is a certain age
okay so uh and obviously they can do
that without the eight percent tax
do you really think an eight percent tax
uh
is going to hurt you economically when
someone is going to buy it
i guess directly from the manufacturer
the beverage manufacturer
uh why why would they want to pay an
eight percent tax when they can buy it
for you for
with no tax right well i i agree i mean
they should be buying it
for us um not seeing the amendment um
the war the language that we had seen
tossed around
included everybody i mean so this would
also allow distributors to
sell direct to a consumer
uh distributors have always had that
right
as a matter of fact i was remembering
the old days
when whenever i wanted you know for
college when i don't want to get a keg
you the place to get the keg was going
directly to the distributor
distributors have always had the right
to to sell now whether they direct ship
no they probably be more than welcome to
deliver it right to your door
exactly and and they would have that
right to do that so they
they don't even need the shipping
because they can deliver it to you
so i'm i'm a little confused why senator
125 is a beverage manufacturer bill but
again i i will see that when we when we
get it
right okay all right well thank you very
much
thank you now oh i have another hand up
and so rep representing clear you now
have a question
i hear your hand is up chris yeah
you have a question chris yes i i
dropped out
and uh you're back knocked out somehow
and i'm trying to get back in and you're
i'm not showing up
uh well we don't see your smiling face
that's true but we see
you and you got a square so you just
have to turn on your video if done
might be maybe not because
didn't well that's right you had it it
was the internet i just moved him in
so he should be able because he was an
attendee again he was an attendee again
right
but i saw him on my screen here but i
don't know when you allow him to
talk when he's allowed to talk as an
attendee he shows up on the screen but
he's still an attendee so now he's a
panelist you know just when i thought i
had this thing down to us
that's tricky okay
okay there you are beautiful you can see
it i can see the uh
the the the ship behind you
all right okay so is anybody else would
like to speak on
um senate bill 14 seeing them then now i
will officially close the public hearing
on senate bill 14.
and how are we doing for time 10 o'clock
we must be behind now
that's probably not planned when i
scheduled this you're
doing well doing okay thank you
all right the reason i schedule these
bills the morning so everybody has
afternoon
so they can go do something fun since
the weather is supposed to be nice
so but not necessarily tomorrow it's
weather afternoon weather but
tonight today will be a good day to get
out all right senate bill
open up the public hearing and senate
bill 17 brew pubs allowing customer to
bring
dogs the outdoor this looks familiar too
okay all right so uh
this bill is um
um okay
and who's my senator here for this one
regina bertel oh again regina there you
are
perfect sorry have you been on the whole
time that's great
i have been actually i've been listening
okay good
but you're not on the commerce committee
so you can't help me tell me what's
going on with senate bill 125
no i can't but i can look at the
calendar and let you know what happened
to it
okay we'll see it happen yeah okay so uh
go ahead and introduce
this senate bill 17. thank you mr chair
again for the record my name is regina
bartzel state senator for district 19
which encompasses the towns of derry
hampstead and windham
and i'm here to introduce senate bill
17.
i'm the prime sponsor and it's relative
to brew pubs allowing customers to bring
dogs to the outdoor areas and enabling
um and the second part is enabling nano
breweries and brew pubs to enter into
contracts with contract brewers
i will speak to the first part and i
think senator sherman is on
he um in on
paragraph the new paragraph two he will
probably speak
to because that's his um his amendment
that we added to my bill
so uh basically what the
prime bill was to allow um with the
municipalities
um adoption of an ordinance allowing
brew
allowing person to hold brew pub license
it allows the brew pubs to have
their customers bring their um
dogs to the brew pubs but only in the
outdoor patio
areas i believe this passed the senate
last year and i think it might have
passed the house but i can't remember
but
again it got lost in the senator
patricia because i mean
representative petrucci saying no so i
definitely passed the hou
the senate and um i think it got lost in
the omnibus bills last year so
that's my portion in a nutshell
so uh this issue has passed the house uh
uh
in past years not okay and it did pass
this committee
um but it wasn't limited to just uh
brewpubs it was open to all restaurants
that have outside
outdoor seating and the issue was that
we definitely don't want the dogs
indoors because that could be
with uh um dogs that are or have a
or have a mission and um so that it
would only be
outdoors and but it was so can you
address why you're doing brew pubs and
not all restaurants that have outdoor
seating
well it does have um it does amend 466
and i um and i looked at 466 colon 44
and it looks like it does a restaurants
do allow them on the patios but it may
just be the owner's
dog from what i was um was reading
[Laughter]
i'd be open to amendment allowing but um
i wanted to start um with a small bite
of the apple with brew pubs
okay well take a little little step
small paw babies yes puppy paws
yes okay uh do we have any questions for
representative burrissell yes
representative burroughs
yes thank you for taking my question um
senator was one of the motivations for
this
um bill on in terms of the dogs
to actually increase business because
you have a lot of people traveling with
their dogs now and going out to eat so
it would actually
benefit the um these establishments
financially
that was that was a piece of it but the
prime reason was i actually had some
brew pubs come to me and they had lost
customers because hhs came in and told
them they couldn't have the dogs on the
patios so
some of the brew pubs did come to me and
asked me to
change the or add this to the rsas to
allow that so that they can
um their customers can bring their their
uh dogs
thank you you had me at wolf thank you
okay representative um i assume that
this
means the dog must be on the leash is
that written into the uh
law i believe um that would be a local
ordinance and i think it
i've actually been reading some of the
uh
comments on some of our community pages
and i believe it's actually a state law
that dogs have to be on leashes
thank you representative pilot
thank you mr chair well you're right
we've heard this before
um and some of the issues that that i
have with this
mirror what the dhhs sent out to us
with um objections such as um you can't
control where a dog defecates or
irritates
whether it's out on a patio who cleans
it up
there's you know nothing that that
presents this um would the staff of the
restaurant
be responsible how would other customers
deal with
a dog that was aggressive um
would there be would the owner of the
business have the ability to
deny a customer that was there
with a dog if there was a problem with
that dog
would they be liable if they
determined that the dog was aggressive
or not behaved was
a affecting other dogs that could be
in the area i mean there's there's a lot
of other questions that are not
addressed in this bill
and i i my own opinion is that
there are um
public safety and sanitary issues
when you have dogs around food and i
just don't think that the
that i mean how how does this bill
address
some of those concerns
i appreciate your your uh comments and
your question and i i think
what would happen is and it it
i mean if you go to portsmouth they'll
they allow dogs on the on the patios i
think it would be a local ordinance
that if the town or the city
wants to add that um that capability to
allow their brew problems
and it's really up to the brew pubs to
address
go to the town the selectmen or the um
council and say we this is what we'd
like to do and then
they need to work out an ordinance that
would work for them
thank you okay uh representative
um thank you i was just gonna ask a
little bit of something along the same
line as to how we can
make some of these issues go away a
little bit i i personally own
the cutest little puppy she's adorable
and sweet but she
um she's a pain in the butt and so i
would not want to subject
someone having a nice hamburger on a
nice sunny day
and a beer uh to to her cuteness
and and yet i do respect the idea that
pet owners
with pandemic puppies and such are out
there and are looking for ways to
incorporate their pets and their social
lives
a little bit more so i guess my question
is are you aware of any means by which
we can
facilitate localities coming up with
ways to make it easier for nano brewers
to have these
pup these these pet possibilities
well thank you for the question and i i
have to agree i mean i have
a 11 month old standard poodle puppy and
at this point i would not bring her to a
brewery i would not even bring her
to home depot at this point until she
gets
she gets a little bit more trained but
again i think it's really
the agreement between the nano breweries
and
nano breweries slash restaurants however
brew pubs um for them to do
to for them to negotiate
uh a standard for their locale
with the town uh council or the
um selectmen
i realize this is a difficult question
but thank you for tackling it for me
yeah the statue of the bill uh
specifically says a municipality may
adopt an ordinance so
so obviously the municipality will weigh
in and it does
i was looking at just uh having advising
patrons that dogs are allowed on the
premise
in other states in colorado the one i'm
thinking of in particular where
a lot of people have their dogs outside
um the sign
the scientists says well-behaved dogs
are
permitted exactly that's why mine won't
go anywhere near one
so i i assume that uh municipalities
have given the authority to the owner to
address the issue and for someone who
lives in a summer community who
requires everyone to pick up after their
dog
and we're pretty well equipped to handle
what they leave behind so
any other questions from the committee
members for
the senator seeing them we thank you
again
thank you okay so uh next
up is another senator
who also has an amendment onto this bill
so uh senator sherman you want to
introduce your
portion of this bill please yes thank
you can you hear me
mr chairman yeah okay uh
good uh good morning and um
i just i appreciate senator birdsall
well let me for the record my name is
tom sherman i'm state senator for
district 24 which is 11 towns on the
seacoast
with multiple brew pubs and
i just want to thank senator bertsel for
working with me to allow me to attach
this amendment
to the to her bill
essentially this amendment affects
two different levels of breweries nano
brews and brew pubs
you i'm sure are aware mr chair
the idea of adding contract brewers to
our
repertoire in new hampshire is something
that occurred a few years ago
and when i talked to the beverage
association and
others they said it seems like it was a
little bit of an
oversight not to include nano breweries
and brew pubs
but be that as it may in my district
there is a brew pub called wim brewery
and they approached me as they were
looking to expand their capacity
but the cost of the overhead locally
would have been prohibitive
they could not do tenant brewing which
is allowed
just from a logistics standpoint and the
overhead that would be involved in that
however they were able to find sorry tom
you want to talk about the difference
between tenant and contract
so people are sure good question yeah so
uh
i'm not super expert on this but i will
do my best
tenant brewing is contract booing is
where
you give your recipe to add a
operating large brewer and
they will actually brew to your recipe
and your specifications on contract
tenant brewing is where you go into a
similar facility
that has more capacity but you bring in
your own people your own you're
basically using their equipment
so currently tenant brewing is allowed
for nano pubs
and brew pubs but
it again as you can imagine it requires
a significant
investment in overhead and personnel to
do that
so what contract brewing would allow
in both of these is say you have
a barrel a month production which is not
much
you have a very popular recipe and you
want to
increase your capacity you're basically
testing the waters you're thinking about
a future investment
it's much less expensive to do this
through a contract brewer where
they will actually create your recipe
at your specification the amounts you
want
and then you bring it back and sell it
at your brewery
or at your brew pub that way if it takes
off then
number one you have some funds to
reinvest locally
into your brewpub or nanobrew and number
two
you know that some of the risk
is less because it actually is
successful
the other benefits of the concept of
allowing contract brewing staying
completely within the limits that are
already imposed on nano brews and brew
pubs
is that the nano brew and brew pub
as i said will be able to expand
capacity
without a huge financial risk the
contract brewers
like it because they typically will put
you in in places where they have
gaps in production so it's not
that you're competing with their current
production times
my understanding is that they they are
able to fill out their um
there are times when the when the
brewery is not
actually producing and they can fill in
those gaps
the third is that the customers have
more accessibility to your product and
the fourth
of course is that the state sees the
increased revenue
of increased production um
so the bill is or the the amendment is
fairly simple
it uh allowed the the biggest hurdle
in working with the liquor commission
was how do we know if somebody is
starting from scratch
how do we know what the production
levels are and we wanted to be sure that
we stuck with the spirit
of brew pubs and mana brews which is
that you're brewing on site
so two of the requirements you'll see in
the in the
amendment are number one they have to
continue to brew on site
and it has to be at the level they were
brewing on site
prior to on an annualized basis
prior to contract brewing second of all
if they're starting from scratch you
just can't do it you have to establish
your level of production and it has to
be at least
10 barrels per year which isn't a lot
but it it would allow pretty much
every nano brew or brew pub that wanted
to contract brew it would allow them
that capacity
and certainly wim brewery which has a
very tiny facility in hampton
would be able to meet that that
that hurdle of 10 per year
again it respects the spirit
of brew pubs and nanopubs where you have
on-site brewing
it respects the current limits to
production
but it allows expansion of these
these small businesses without
putting them at enormous financial risk
and
i'm not sure if whim will be testifying
today i hope they will but
their estimate just to get up to uh
a fraction of what they can do with
contract brewing was going to be a 350
to 500 000
outlay in capital so that was a big
concern
uh for uh for a small operation um
so with that i will stop my testimony
and happy to take any questions you
might have okay
uh we do have some questions
representative bartlett is first
oops thank you mr chair um
um senator sherman um now i
i i had asked um senator bernstein
bertsell about um this being an enabling
um bill and and she answered that you
know that's what the intent
is here and so we're getting into a lot
of detail about the difference you know
between a nano brewery and
who can do this but my concern really is
about
the fact that the state is
promoting um the ability to bring dogs
onto a eating establishment premise
senator sherman is just here for the for
this piece with
the dogs we're that's for side for the
moment but he's
he's here for discussing just this
contract
brewing for brew pups
but this is the amendment to the dogs
uh in the senate's mind this is a now an
omnibus spill that has multiple
questions
oh boy i got lost there along the way
um so i'm not seeing the amendment and i
looked in my emails
this is in the bill this is actually in
the bill
it's part two of the bill they said the
senate well
yes actually section three of the bill
so it's uh so yeah so they they
will get buckle your seatbelts we're
going to see a little more of this when
we see senate bills that there are going
to be multiple
issues in in thank you very much
no problem representative
weston yes thank you mr chair and thank
you senator sherman for bringing this
i i did sort of zero in on the
production
levels when i was reading this uh
because being somebody who's not in the
business uh i was curious about the
the limits the lowest limit and the
highest limit
and i noticed that the difference
between the
um the brew pro pubs and the nano brewer
were different and i'm wondering
if um the the
brew pubs are allowed to produce more
than the nano brewery and i wonder if
you could tell me why that is
uh i would love to except that we didn't
change that
that uh that's existing statute the the
limits of production are
um perhaps the chairman will remember
well i would say i would clarify that
even though the title of the bill
does say nano this section of the bill
only talks about brew pub
no i actually i'm sorry it actually does
address
both nano breweries and brew pubs
neither of them right
neither of them had the capacity to
contract brood
and so the concept is that
nano brews and brew pubs
are very similar in structure they
actually are sitting different
you know very close to each other in
statute but they both have the same
concerns is that
you know they are typically very small
operations
with limits on production
but being able to put in the investment
to expand
is is a combination of risk and
finding the capital and so the ability
to contract brew
allows them to test the waters at a
lower overhead they both currently as
i'm sure you know mr chair they have
similar structure and statute in that
they can both
tenant brew they can locally brew and
all this does
is for both of them it gives them the
capacity to contract brew
because they both face the same hurdle
yeah i see it now it's so
this section two of the bill is nano
section
three section three is proof
what really begs the question then you
know bruh
you're taking two statutes who were
born how would i say this is uh
awkwardly
from uh what we had which was a beverage
manufacturer
and the brew hub was a cute idea that
that
someone who was really going to make
that big investment to put in the big
tanks and everything
because they thought people would like
to watch it being made and watch that
whole process
and you're saying well yeah that's why
we have that license but they really
don't want to do that they
they just want to make a barrel a day
there and the rest of it's going to be
somewhere else
okay i guess they don't feel so bad
given that prove ups pay the
highest license they pay a cocktail
beverage license
all right uh so that for that privilege
but when you start throwing in nano
nano the license is slow the fees low
the volume was low because it was
supposed to be where you were
experimenting and trying out something
new but to go and
do it somewhere else it it defeats the
whole purpose of what the nano was
supposed to be about
just understood so uh i am not
wedded to nanos because that's not
the constituency that brought this
forward nano were nano people involved
in that in this or how did this get into
the bill then
no it was there because uh
in discussing this with
beverage manufacturers and others and
the association
the feeling was that nano and brew pubs
share the same concern about as they
want to expand as their recipes are
popular
again it is you know these are small
operations and the ability to either get
capital or raise capital
to be able to expand is limited so
i absolutely hear what you're saying um
if you'll notice on the brewpub side
it was very intentional the work i did
and working with the chair of the liquor
commission to be sure that we
kept the spirit of the brew pubs which
was the focus of this the nano which is
that you have to have on-site brewing it
has to be at least at the level you were
doing before
and um and and you can't do it
unless you start out and demonstrate the
ability to do
a certain level of on-site brewing
so i think that's all in keeping with
the brew pub the nano brew was added on
as uh at the request of others
um if you wanted to jettison that
you know i wouldn't uh
be seriously wounded they'll be back
if we pass this bill they'll be back
next year so
right but but i think the on the brewpub
side
absolutely we did everything we possibly
could
to keep the spirit of a brewpub alive
you know if if they stop on-site brewing
there's no reason they shouldn't
go for a production license and a
restaurant license
that's that's what they're doing you
know they're doing production off-site
then they're doing a restaurant but a
brew pub where it's combined
again as you know it is a significant
financial
risk to expand and this would be a way
to allow
that to happen to the benefit of pretty
much
all parties including the customer the
state
the contract brewers and the brew pubs
without and i
i don't believe it violates the spirit
of the
of a brewpub i think it really does meet
that spirit
i don't want to get in a running debate
but as you know the brew pub
is the poster trial of throwing the
three-tier system into the trash can
and the whole running concept was
that they are absolutely making an
investment into all those tanks and all
that production right there
on site to say you said well you pass
this then that will help them out
no i i can visualize they'll start
pulling those tanks out and say we don't
we can use that space for more tables
more customers so because we're brewing
the stuff off-site
so well that's you know
so maybe we maybe need a new name for
it's not really a brew pub it's you know
it's somebody who is a
is an outlet of some brewing
manufacturing that's going on somewhere
else
location well just to answer that
concern
they do have they can't pull that out
and continue production on site at the
same level they were doing it before
they just came a month one barrel a
month is nothing
right but what i know home brewers to do
more than that
but but what i'm saying is that they
have a certain
on-site investment uh and
that on-site investment they have to
continue at at least that level or they
have to change their license they can't
do it
unless they continue that and that's in
the amendment that but
that doesn't make the question if you
became a new brewpub number somebody
opening up a brew pub after this law is
passed they can have
have this minimum standard of one barrel
a month
and and be doing it off-site and so it
just seems to stretch to call it a brew
pub
when when you have to go looking for the
tanks
i mean most brew pubs the tanks are
right there they're these big you know
silos missiles that are parked right
inside there you're taking them out
so anyway i i get it i get it
senator chairman it's not that i'm
opposed to the bill i just it just it's
just
sometimes it's a wonder okay
representative abel has a question
uh yes this is a a procedural question
really for the chair
i think um i just want to
clarify for myself and for everyone else
about
uh is there a word germaness
i don't know uh but uh it sound
if a bill comes to us uh
from the senate and it has different
parts but
they're not what the house would
generally consider to be germaine
we can accept that but if we
want if we want to make
an amend introduce an amendment
ourselves
do we have to divide the bill into two
bills so that we're
germaine with the one part or do we just
go go go forward um because we're
dealing with two different issues here
so how how do we
how do we handle that um well clearly
the house and senate have different
rules about germanius
and um in the house we we require that
if it's a non-german amendment it has to
be
hold a separate public hearing but uh
and that's true for everything except um
house bill 2 which is allowed to be
chock full of anything and everything
um we the senate uh uh has
in historically and in in overwhelmingly
the
session uh have uh have put added bills
to each other and
and and they have decided again to do it
again this year and that's their choice
and if they send the bill over
we we take the bill as is in whatever
pieces whatever sections we want
and we're free to add our own sections
and we're removing sections and then
we'll take it up in the committee a
conference
and at that point the committee
conference has to has to deal with only
those things that are in
those two different versions they cannot
introduce a new
non-germain amendment at that point
okay any other questions for
senator sherman
seeing none we thank you very much thank
you
and let's see i do have let me see where
my
yeah did you say you want something else
say something no i'll get you all set
okay
um so
let's see where i have who was going to
speak on this bill
um so if someone else signed up to speak
would just raise their hand
so i can find okay all right henry value
all right where's henry on this one
okay you just have to unmute yourself
[Music]
henry
okay uh thank you very much uh mr
chairman
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is henry value
and i'm here on behalf of the new
hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
and we would just ask if the committee
is going to move this bill forward
that you expand the bill to include
all restaurants the house commerce
committee
last session uh passed house bill 1438
came out of your committee uh it went to
the floor
it passed the house and it was sent to
the senate
and then covert came along and the bill
just went
anywhere it was laid on the table and uh
the session ended so it
it never made it all the way to the
finish line
uh but uh this committee did pass
uh the bill last year to allow
basically allow dogs in outdoor dining
areas
at restaurants so it would expand it
beyond what this bill
is looking to do which is just the brew
pubs
and that's it okay
and i would just add mr chairman that i
sent a copy of house bill 1483 as passed
by the house
and senate bill 450 is passed by the
senate last year
to all the committee members a little
while ago so you can
they are very different 450 is identical
to
the first section of senate bill 17
but that was part of the confusion i
think
all right yeah i kept i was a little
fuzzy there okay great thank you
any questions for henry
may you say none okay uh next up is bob
levine
and i'm promoting a bob
and go ahead thank you mr chairman
members of the committee um my name's
robert levine i'm one of the owners of
the
wim craft pub and brewery
in hampton new hampshire
we're the ones that have the really
small
brewing facilities it allows us to brew
basically one barrel a month um
we would like to expand um
finding the financing to equip us to a
seven-barrel brewery which is
what had been in our business plan which
would satisfy
our brewing requirements would require
an additional investment of 350 000
at a minimum just the equipment alone is
000 never mind the expansion of space
while we can tenant brew under the
statute
tenant brewing is a long-term commitment
business commitment with an established
beverage manufacturer
requires uh federal registration
and approval uh in in
in more financial risk as senator
sherman explained
it we would go in and utilize the
facilities with our own personnel
it's it's a much more intensive
commitment uh
in business risk for us contract brewing
uh which beverage manufacturers can do
and these are the people with the big
equipment anyway
um allows us to go in
to a beverage manufacturer on a one-off
basis
um it our capital investment
is for example uh with uh
we've contracted with great north um to
do this and then found out that we
weren't allowed to under the statute
according to liquor commission
after we sent in the contract for
approval um
that would cost us ten thousand dollars
and that would get us a 20 barrel
run of probably one of our best recipes
and in that way we could test the market
see how uh brewing on that production
level is received
without having to
[Music]
make a much more intensive investment
it's a one-off deal
if it works out we like the way that
beverage manufacturer
does that
production with our recipe then we could
continue to do
so without
the financial risk
it levels the playing field a little bit
for us and nano brewers
in order to enjoy some of those benefits
without the additional cost
in no way shape or form would we ever
consider
removing our brewing equipment on site
that this is our business model we could
have chosen to be a restaurant
we didn't we chose to be a brewpub
one of my partners is a brewer and
that's what he wishes to do he's our
head brewer
uh so we asked the the committee to
to favorably look upon the the amendment
and the bill um and thank you i'll
be happy to take any questions
okay there's uh any any questions from
the committee members
uh cnn thank you very much for your
testimony thank you
okay uh so um we'll
change uh see now i'm david
just stall david dustel russell
dave i'm promoting you up to so you can
testify
good morning and thank you everyone for
the chance to speak
just give me a nod or a hand wave of my
audio's coming through we
we hear you great excellent thank you
i did send an email to the committee so
i will try to keep this brief because
hopefully uh folks have at least scanned
it um
i want to make it clear i like brew pubs
nana brews i support it i look forward
to
getting back into it uh once we're able
um and i think it's it's a real shame
that
this very wise granting of contractual
flexibility is entangled with
a a possibly more contentious issue
which is the issue of dogs in outdoor
dining areas now
the issue of the sanitary uh concerns
and the hhs objections
that that's a well-worn path i think
it's totally valid but i'm not going to
bother to repeat it here i want to make
some points
that are i think also valid and i also
want to uh
yeah so let me just get on with that um
there are
plenty of people who want to allow dogs
in the outdoor eating and drinking areas
i totally get that and i get that that
people in favor of this are going to be
very vocal and very enthusiastic there's
also a significant
constituency of us who do not want this
but i think the problem is that many of
us who don't want it are
aware of the status quo comfortable with
the status quo and not aware that there
might be change on the horizon so what
i'm saying is that i think opposing
voices are underrepresented because a
lot of people are simply not aware of it
um and representative van van houten um
with with apologies if i mispronounce
your last name i think
you're you brought a nice perspective to
this saying i have a dog i love my dog
i wouldn't bring my dog to a pub and i
definitely um
appreciate that i think we a lot of us
have
anecdotal experience of of maybe one dog
in an eating area especially if
it's a service dog very very highly
trained doing a job
causing absolutely no problems
whatsoever i think
we need to look into our collective
crystal ball
and think about a scenario with multiple
untrained non-service dogs that are in
an
eating area surrounded by unfamiliar
people surrounded by unfamiliar dogs
with the noise with the smell of food
with
the people in charge of these dogs
drinking alcohol and ask ourselves
is this not a recipe for conflict
and disturbance i think it's just common
sense that there could be a lot of
problems and i want to point out
based on some of the discussion earlier
in this session new hampshire does not
have
a leash law if you read the statute very
carefully the new hampshire state law
says a dog simply must be under
control which is widely interpreted by
many people to be
voice control so expand the crystal ball
here to a bunch of
unleashed dogs because that's what this
legislation would do
and let's ask ourselves the question do
do
a lot of pub managers and do a lot of
local police departments
really want to be getting involved in
what i and
what i think are the guaranteed
conflicts and the guaranteed problems
that are going to happen
especially when assertions about
increased revenue increased business
are right no guarantee
to give a quick anecdotal example i was
on the outdoor dining patio at the
whaleback ski area in enfield just this
past weekend
and there was a group at a table next to
me with a dog
on a leash i went back to my car to
change out of my ski boots and as soon
as i came back to my table
their dog on its leash was sitting there
and nuzzling through my backpack trying
to eat my snacks
and the response to them was oh you
should kick the dog
when it does that and my response was i
will not kick a dog
ever it's cruel and it's not my job to
keep your dog out of my backpack so
anecdotal story i don't want to get hung
up on it i don't want to move on to
reasons that don't have to do with
whether a person likes dogs or doesn't
like dogs
so please please think of these as
objectively as possible when there's a
pandemic
like now and like unfortunately there
probably will be in the future
people who don't want to eat around dogs
do not
really have a feasible choice to simply
go inside
and eat or drink without the dogs around
and even if we did is it correct that
one group of people
should be empowered to displace another
group of people for no good reason
i think it's worth recognizing that dogs
are extremely popular no doubt
but the best statistics i've found which
by the way were sponsored by pet food
companies and pet accessory companies
still find that dogs are owned by a
minority of u.s households now
being in a minority doesn't make
somebody wrong and being in a majority
doesn't make somebody right but the
point is
a large constituency should not be
displaced by another constituency for
what appears to be no good reason
i think it's also true that we don't
have a lot of outdoor pub space
or outdoor restaurant space in the state
of new hampshire and i think all
citizens deserve to be comfortable using
them
i think it's feasible for people with
dogs to enjoy a pub without their dogs
but it's not feasible for some people to
enjoy a pub when there are other dogs
around
allergies are a real thing uh fears and
phobias are real things
and i think overall it's just
it's just a shame that these two issues
the contractual issue and the dog issue
are bound up together and the dog
issue itself i think is far too
loosey-goosey when you consider that we
don't actually have a statewide leash
law what the proposal here is to
open up outdoor areas to dogs and then
let the towns retroactively make
legislation and policy to address these
problems after they've happened
that seems very short-sighted i think if
dogs are going to be allowed in outdoor
spaces
then the parameters to make it
successful need to be laid out ahead of
time
and i do think they should be laid out
by the state because i have
experience at the town level of people
saying look we're not comfortable
making ordinances ordinances that go
beyond the state standard
i think it would be best if there was
some way to separate the very wise
business portion of the bill the
contractual portion from the societal
aspect about whether or not
people want to or should be able to
drink and eat around dogs
i don't know if it's possible for the
bill to be split up i don't know if it's
possible for something like dog friendly
dining to be restricted to a certain
number of days per month so that each
constituency can get what they want or
something like that but right now
this looks like it's far too vague far
too open-ended it doesn't have any
specificity to it to set it up for
success
and there's a large number of people who
are opposed to it
many of them are unaware and that's why
they're not being heard thank you for
your time
well thank you uh does anybody uh any
members of the committee have a question
uh
cnn we thank you very much for your
testimony
uh so similar on this line we'll now
have
colleen smith from department of hhs
good morning good morning chairman hunt
and members of the committee
for the record my name is colleen smith
i'm the administrator of the food
protection section within the department
of health and human services
and i'm here to provide some background
information regarding the current
regulations around the allowance of dogs
and food establishments
so as alluded to previously rsa 466
prohibits bringing animals into any
restaurant or retail store that sells
food except under two conditions
service animals or a restaurant owner's
own
properly disciplined dog is is allowed
in non-food preparation areas pro
provided there's proper
notification to patrons that there is a
dog on premises
our food code which we've adopted into
our administrative rules
does not allow companion dogs on
premises
and food establishments and there are
several public health reasons that
should be considered before
approving expansion of this law to allow
for unlimited dogs
amount of dogs to be present in a food
establishment
we are concerned that patrons or
restaurant staff may pet or other
otherwise handle the dogs contaminating
their hands without
washing them and then going on to
prepare food or handle tableware for
other patrons
the that the dogs may contaminate the
chairs with their saliva
or from dander or fur which
could also be an allergen to that may
affect other patrons
and then also that dogs may have
accidents that could contaminate
the dining areas and there's no
provisions about
protocols or procedures for who would be
responsible
and and what would be necessary for for
proper cleanup
should that happen i would be happy to
answer any questions that you have
with regard to the current regulation
uh we do have a question representative
bartlett thanks very much mr chair
and thank you for coming to see us again
as always um
miss smith um one of the things i'm
wondering is
is there any provision for um whether a
patron
if the if this kind of a bill were to be
passed
whether the patron would have to um
carry insurance what if this dog
were to bite someone or another dog
is there anything in this that currently
that
that would require the well would make
the restaurant owner liable for one
thing
or keep the owner of the dog liable
um with insurance
so i i am not aware that the bill
addresses those two aspects you raise
for
two very good points um those wouldn't
be specifically addressed in our food
safety rules but but i
think you raised two points that
should be also under consideration
thanks very much
so do you have rules related now to
dogs i mean like i know we have the the
pub the the you know
but the bed breakfast statue where we
allow dogs do
did you guys ever generate rules along
some of these issues
so the only allowances currently are
around
the um the specific carve-outs related
to to service animals and then also that
the restaurant owner
there aren't specific rules within those
um it's it's just covered within the
statute that they're
that they're limited i think what we we
hear
often is that folks you know even though
there is rules and
um a statute in place around this issue
is that
consumers still bring their dogs to
places we we deal with many many
consumer complaints
um several a month with regard to this
issue not only restaurants but into
retail
stores as well
okay any other questions from the
committee members
so you know we thank you very much for
coming in
uh and last but not least is aiden moore
from the liquor commission
thank you mr chairman uh i'm really here
to see if there are any
technical questions that the committee
members might have and if not
i thank you for the opportunity to be
here
so otherwise you're okay with the
language in the
three sections of the bill well we
participated
as senator sherman indicated in working
through some of the
issues dealing with the contract brewing
pieces so while
i can't speak to the dog questions uh
i'm certainly happy
to suggest that our our cooperation with
the senator was
part of what was brought to you in his
portion of the amendment
okay great and you're willing to take
questions i hope i'm certainly happy to
take some
representative bartlett has a question
thank you very much
and thank you for sticking around mr
moore um
my question is um
i don't know how many of these very very
small
brew breweries that there are um i think
that as a rule we try not to
come up with bills that only apply to
one or two businesses
do you in your experience know whether
there are there is a need for this bill
because there are many of these one
barrel a month
breweries uh
thank you for your question
representative uh i i believe you
heard from the uh owner of the
uh brewpub that they are and i believe
they are the smallest
manufacturing uh brewpub
in the state that their
brewing capacity is probably the
smallest so
i i wouldn't pretend to suggest i know
whether it's needed
or not um i think
senator sherman gave you compelling
information
about the business aspects of why they
want to do that
and i think representative hunt
probably gave you a lot of good
background information on the
political questions about brew pubs and
nanobrewers
as far as what they were put in place
and intended to do so i would probably
suggest that
we really don't have a position on
whether it's a good idea or not
and would certainly defer to the to the
committee to determine
whether it's an appropriate concept to
move forward
further question vanquier thanks very
much um can you tell us
how many of these very very small um
brew breweries are in new hampshire
well when you say small representative
are you speaking about
nanobrewers alone or are you speaking
about
i can get you statistics and numbers of
the
different categories of manufacturers so
for example
we have a beverage manufacturer which is
a class of license
on its own we have brewpubs which again
are another type of license
and we have nanobrewers and i'd be happy
to provide you with the exact number of
those businesses
i can't give it to you right now but i'd
be happy to get that to you today
i think that would be helpful like an
idea of how many of these very very
small
um breweries there are in new hampshire
i'll make sure you have that today
representative thanks very much
representative abramson
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my question
uh maybe this is more appropriate as a
question for the chair but i think the
title is
relative to brew pubs allowing customers
to bring door
dogs into outdoor areas and
enabling nano breweries to brew pub
and brew pubs to enter into contracts
with contract brewers it
seems like um this is two
completely different bills i wonder if
we're allowed to divide the question
ourselves
the way we would be allowed to on the
floor uh
we are perfectly allowed to do whatever
we want with this bill
anything send it send it out as two
bills we could add more things
well now we can't send two bills because
then you would have to have another bill
so
you can divide the question like you say
on the house floor and vote for one
issue and not the other
um but otherwise uh we can
delete section two of the bill and you
know say we don't want to put nanos in
here
we can do anything like with that but
you can't create a separate bill you
would you can
you can you can add and subtract
amendments to it
i'm just saying this i guess it's
foregone conclusion the second part of
the bill
shouldn't have any problems but this
first part about dogs in outdoor areas
could
jeopardize the second part of the bill
so i'm i'm wondering if we can divide
the question in committee
if you think it's that's important
enough we could
certainly uh delete that
section of the bill but then and then
and then go stick it on a different one
for instance we could take section one
out of this bill and go
throw it in senate bill 125 when it
comes to us
you know we can we can move things
around like that but um
you can't create a separate bill now you
can't have a whole separate bill they
for better for worse the senate has has
uh tagged them together and
and i'm sure that was around the
conversation of jermaine's that that
in both cases they were talking about
brewpubs
all right thank you okay any other
questions for
tony moore well
you get offline thank you
all right uh seeing no more hands up
anybody in the attendees last chance
uh there were 12 people in support of
the bill
and one person opposed and one person
neutral
which i assume that was the yeah that
was calling
okay with that i will close the public
hearing on senate bill 17.
and next up is
senate bill uh
senate bill 66 allowing on-premise
licensees to transport beverages and
wines for delivery to consumers
okay so um the sponsor or anybody of the
attendees
who want to speak please raise your hand
so i can see you
and so
who's the sponsor of this one
you're french french oh harold you know
what i got a call from harold that
and i'm sure you must have called me to
tell me that he could not be here to
introduce the bill
so representative would you like to
introduce the bill for senator french
yes uh mr chairman i would because
senator french also called me
perfect okay and uh for the record
representative john patosik from
rockingham six which is derry
uh standing in for senator french uh
introducing house a house bill senate
bill 66
fn which is
let me quote this for the record
allowing on-premises licensees to
transport beverages and wines for
delivery to customers
uh this bill allows an on-premise
licensee to purchase a restaurant
delivery license in order to deliver
beverages and wine
with food ordered for the on-premise
licensee
[Music]
i read it i understand it
it is a result of covid
and uh if there's any technical issues
i'm sure
uh attorney moore would be happy to
address them
and uh i will stand back at this time
thank you mr chair okay great
uh next is jamie burnett
okay jamie you're on
good morning mr chairman can you hear me
okay yes we can
uh just out of respect for your time
this morning i know things are running a
little late i'm gonna be very brief
we've testified uh i testified before on
behalf of the wine institute
on similar legislation in this committee
uh we
we fully support um sb 66 we think it's
a timely measure to
help out restaurants and
on-premises licensees that have been
struggling during the pandemic
it certainly would help out uh wine
manufacturers as well
which we represent and we have provided
written testimony to you you have that
if you have any questions i'll answer
them but um we we support the bill and
hope you'll consider passing it
great any questions for jamie
saying none thank you very much uh
now we have brian moran
good morning chairman hunt and members
of the committee my name is brian moran
i'm director of government affairs for
the new england convenience store
and energy marketers association
we represent about 900 convenience
stores in new hampshire
and 655 which sell motor fuels we employ
over
14 000 people uh nexima
has commented on this bill several times
before
uh in the senate as well as in this
committee
and uh you know we certainly appreciate
the you know intentions to you know
provide some relief
and what we would like to suggest for
the committee's consideration
where we would not oppose the bill of
three
changes could be made and the first
would be
you know given that we're trying to
replicate the dine-in
experience to go we would recommend that
the volumes of alcohol
that would be allowed for to go under
this new license category
should be reduced you know from from its
current
19 12 ounce beverages or
one and a half liters of wine to
something that is more comparable to
that dine-in experience the second is
as it was amended in the senate it has a
two-year sunset provision and we would
request
that that be reduced to one year
and believe that there's adequate time
to be able to
evaluate the utility and necessity of
this license category going forward
and along those same lines we would
request
uh that the new licensees
under this category would be able to
report
you know at some timely basis
you know the the beverages and wine
volumes that were sold
with the meals to go uh to be able to
determine whether
this is truly necessary and
of value uh for this category as
the uh uh i with the idea of evaluating
this trial
uh an experiment going forward
um with that i'd be open to any
questions
okay any questions from committee
members
i'm saying okay thank you
and as anybody else wants to speak other
than
tony moore uh
i guess that's it all right oh and i'm
mike summers okay here we go
i was wondering where you guys were
okay mike i'm promoting you up good
morning
good morning chairman hunt members of
the committee
uh record my name is mike summers i'm
the president ceo of the future lodging
and restaurant association
and just to give a little context um
this bill that most of the majority of
this bill was actually filed in the
early part of the 2020 session uh
senator french had filed this bill on
our behalf we were pursuing this
as something the industry would like to
try obviously then covet hit and
everything kind of went sideways on us
the industry etc
and uh the governor was kind enough to
adopt this under an emergency order
which has allowed the industry
to essentially experiment with this for
the you know for the last year
so uh we're here testifying in support
of uh senate bill 66
certainly hope that you will uh we'll
move this forward
we have two two two minor changes that
we would request
and the two small changes are right at
the end of page three
lines eighteen and nineteen um
ultimately
what i think we have concerned with is
the two-year sunset provision
uh as you all know uh certainty for
industry is an important uh
factor and so uh if we're going to go
through this entire process it would
make sense to us as the industry
make this a permanent right and feature
for the industry to
to pursue and and i will say that the
the consumers have responded uh pretty
positively over the course of the
pandemic as you know
uh we were we've had a very tough year
uh stating the obvious
um you know that uh you know we were
closed for a number of months there
and obviously one of our biggest outlets
only outlet was take out delivery and
the part of that
obviously was uh beer and wine as part
of a you know a meal package
um so that certainly uh has helped some
businesses
you know uh there's uh some folks that
have said that uh you know it's it's not
that big a piece of business and frankly
they're right it's not a huge piece of
business for the industry but
for those industry members that have
pursued it it's an important piece of
their business so
uh you know we would respectfully
request that that you move this forward
um and then uh
so the two-year sunset really is our
biggest issue there
and the other piece that i would ask for
is if we could this
uh this essentially allows that uh it
would take effect 60 days after passage
um one of the things that i would urge
you to consider is that
if the emergency order is to expire we
don't know when that's going to be
it would make sense for just the
continuity if we could uh pass this
and have it effective as soon as
possible so that there wouldn't be any
gap in the ability for businesses to
have this in a business model and again
goes back to certainty that
if you have the right under the
emergency order the emergency order
expires but then it kicks in as a right
later on
uh it's almost a guarantee that
somebody's gonna get caught selling in
that
in that gap not knowing that they they
weren't didn't have the right to do so
so
we would just respectfully ask that we
uh uh potentially move that to have it
um upon passage so
i think that's uh the extent of my uh
testimony and i'd be happy to try to
answer any questions
okay we do have questions uh
representative weston
thank you mr chair i'm not sure this
question uh
really should go to mike summers it's
more of a general question
we recently discussed hb 593 which was
about the
delivery services like grubhub and
doordash
and i'm wondering how that their
services would mesh with this
new rule representative thank you for
the question and frankly
this wouldn't affect those third-party
delivery systems the way this is drafted
the only way that alcohol could be
delivered they would have to be
delivered by an employee of the
establishment
so whilst your third-party delivery
companies can deliver food they would
not be able to participate
in um in the delivery of alcohol and
frankly that was worked out in the early
days so late
2019 we had met with liquor liquor
commission
uh attorney moore was uh
part of those conversations and we had
essentially talked through
the uh chain of liability chain of
custody and their concerns and
that's how we really established that it
really needed to be an employee that was
going to deliver alcohol so essentially
they would be
left out of this this piece of
legislation
okay thank you thank you uh
representative burroughs yes thank you
for taking my question
mr summers can you tell me if under the
uh emergency order
is there a limit to the amount of
alcohol that can be delivered
uh there is uh and is my understanding
that the amounts in the emergency order
are uh the same as in this bill but
attorney moore would probably be the
answer that could
uh definitely clarify that for you
follow-up please
for the question being clear yeah so my
question is do you agree with um
i believe was mr mourin um who's who
was advocating that um the volume be
limited under this bill do you agree
with that
i don't i think the uh the the limits
that are in the bill i think makes sense
and and that's simply because if you're
in a uh
say you have a few friends over for
dinner you know two bottles of wine is
not going to go very far
when you have five or six people in your
home so i think that uh
you know these are kind of reasonable
amounts i think this is manageable
um and i don't think it's an overly
large quantity of alcohol frankly
and i would also suspect that people are
going to order based on the number of
folks that are there right so they're
not going to order the maximum every
time
if it's a husband and wife having dinner
they're probably getting one bottle of
wine or maybe it's a four pack of
craft brews or something but if you're
having friends over you may need
the the ability to order a little bit
more so that everyone can enjoy a
cocktail
thank you thank you
any other questions from the committee
members
seeing none thank you very much thank
you chairman
thank you and kate frye i'm so glad kate
you
you're gonna weigh in today
and then you're good to go okay just
have to mute yourself
thank you uh can you hear me okay yes we
can
okay thank you very much for allowing me
to testify i have not
signed up to testify um as this
committee knows we have been
opposed to versions of the bill of this
bill because of our concerns around
greater access to alcohol without
necessarily providing any more resources
to um substance use disorder prevention
treatment and recovery services however
i was
we just signed in in opposition on this
bill because we thought the senate
version and the exercises that we had
gone through in the senate
was a fair compromise um i think the
two-year sunset is something we really
feel strongly about
we didn't realize that there was going
to be a move to try to remove
that today um and so if um
the committee chooses to do so then our
uh passive
opposition would ex move to much more
active
um i think that we still don't have the
data every time we ask
really how many groups how many
restaurants are taking advantage of this
what is the volume
we've asked this several times we
haven't gotten an answer
um i think the move the amendment gets
us there a little bit
closer i would agree with the earlier
testimony
um from brian moran that that third
point that he requested would be
something we'd be
interested in knowing too really what is
the volume what are we talking about
here
is this really making a difference and
if that's the case
then when there is time two years after
and we really
reevaluate this we hear the data and
then the legislature can decide
so i really encourage the committee to
um keep the bill as is um how it was
given to you in the senate and keep that
two-year sunset so we can just really
look at
kind of real data and evidence-based
policies regarding alcohol accessibility
going forward
and i thank the committee
thank you kate oh we do have a question
representative you have a
question for ms frye yeah i do
thank you for taking my question if the
data shows that there are
significant volumes uh would that show
that
the program to allow take out alcohol is
successful
if the volume is high in the data i
think there's a number of things that we
could evaluate if that was the case
if if that is high you know if it's
something that is working
sure that's a great point but do we also
know from the data
that there are um appropriate stop
gaps um to make sure that this is um
not affecting for example miners or um
other populations or are there other
improvements we can make from the bill
but you can't make any of those
decisions unless you have that data
okay any other questions for miss fry
c none we thank you very much and
all i have left is uh aiden moore
thank you mr chairman and i appreciate
being
able to answer any questions that the
committee may have on senate bill 66
and uh i'm happy to take those questions
if you haven't
so aiden were you in the room when this
two-year sunset
got stuck in this build uh excuse me i i
did monitor the
senate hearing and i think there was
some
uh question about um
from the senate whether or not um
there was adequate data that would look
at whether or not this was
something that they would like to change
permanently and therefore
i believe the motion was put into put a
two-year sunset
into the bill um so that
the legislature could look at it one
more time and determine whether or not
it's something that they'd like to make
a permanent
public policy i guess it begs the
questions did this happen right after we
put the two-year sunset on the
on the doordash bill uh
i did not participate or listen to the
door dash bill
but i would think that great legislative
minds think alike so
well this is a totally different reason
rick
isn't right now isn't the governor we
allowed to have this right now that
that this is going on by a governor's
order that their alcohol is being
delivered
the the order is has been extended and
to
um answer i forget which representative
posed the question but the
um amount of alcohol in this bill is the
same as what's
allowed by the executive order
the difference in one of the things that
people are looking for as far as
measurement is
that moving forward if this bill were to
pass
now a business would be needing to pay
an additional 250 dollar fee that's
something they don't have to pay for now
and so therefore we would be able to
tell you precisely
how many businesses were taking
advantage of this because of the fact
that they would have to pay the
additional fee
and i think that would go towards
providing um
data to the legislature to new futures
and other
groups who may be interested in
determining whether or not this is a
policy worth pursuing
after the after the sunset period
expires
no that makes no sense because the fee
is in this bill
so yes that's correct we are signing up
for the v right so
mr summers says get rid of the sunset uh
he's
he's saying signing i'm okay with the
fee you know
forever and ever i can't speak for mr
summers but
uh i would okay certainly say he can
speak for himself
no i understand that but i'm just saying
that there they don't seem to have you
know there'd be one thing if
the fee wasn't there but if he is there
so
okay representative ed houghton has a
question
uh yes thank you mr sharon thank you
attorney more um
assuming that some of these bills that
we're talking about that we are seeing
is pandemic driven
um particularly in the area of liquor
were to remain what kind of impact would
there be on what we know
of as our current three-tier system
uh thank you for your question
representative that's a
a huge question and i think
none of us really know exactly how
that's going to shake out
there's certainly a number of changes
that have been proposed
which um my time with the state started
in 1981
when i first joined the liquor
commission's enforcement division
and uh during that time there has there
have been
continual steps to um
i don't want to say consolidate but the
the
clear and distinct lines between retail
wholesale
and manufacturing have become blurred
many of the things that were for example
privileges enjoyed by the retailers are
now
enjoyed by manufacturers
and some of the policies that are being
moved forward they have yet to settle
and we really don't have a clear
idea regarding what the long-term
impact will be certainly there is a
concern about
revenue for the state of new hampshire
and that the liquor commission is
in the liquor alcohol business is an
important source of revenue to the
general fund
as well as uh public health issues and i
think
new futures and ms fry's organization
certainly
tries to keep their finger on the pulse
of public health questions
so you've you've asked a great question
and i i would tell you i i really don't
uh have an answer that i could give you
that would probably be satisfying
the broader question you're asking but
there has been a significant amount of
legislation moving the session dealing
with alcohol
and some of the pieces mesh well some of
the pieces
don't and that's the challenge i think
for the agency potentially to administer
these
should they all pass and i think
probably the legislative services
will be working hard to try to reconcile
issues of that may conflict or where
there
have been passed in two different places
and how to resolve them so
i've tried to be as responsive as i can
to your question representative i
i apologize if if i have not been
and no i realize the nebulous nature of
what i've what i've asked of you and i
appreciate your insights thank you very
much
okay any other questions for attorney
more
uh kate did you put your hand back up
again did you
yes i just i did this sorry to bother
the committee again but i just thought
that
i just wanted to add some clarity on the
question of where the
um two-year sunset came and it was
actually
went back a year ago to when all of
these
omnibus bills happened in the senate and
this was one of them
and because the senate had gotten
several calls and concerns about this
they had actually added in that two-year
sunset in the spring
because that bill was uh vetoed
um that didn't go anywhere and so when
the senate had this bill again
they put back the piece that they had
added in the spring so i just wanted to
add that for clarity
that made me feel so much better today
yes you don't have to i didn't worry
i didn't want to get into the community
of conference and be battling over
sunsets
okay okay thank you very much uh
all right so is there anyone else would
like to speak raise your hand
please otherwise uh
we have let's see what it is
so um
and just briefly mr chairman i want to
let you know that representative mcaleer
had to leave the meeting and he asked me
to to give his
heads up okay yes just let you know that
he he
had an appointment in case i was paying
attention okay great
uh so uh this had uh
nine supporters two opposed no neutral
and oh we do have another hand that just
popped up uh
d clarke
okay uh
who are you
and dee clark you want to introduce
yourself
this is scary
uh you have to unmute yourself i think i
did it can you hear me
yes okay just introduce yourself i'm
doug clark
i uh own um two restaurants in downtown
durham
uh cao trachuria and clarkson american
bistro
uh i uh we located them both in durham
uh we opened them in 2020 which
obviously turned out to be relatively
bad timing
we did call the governor's office to
inquire about the last main street
relief program
and learned that new businesses would
not qualify because we didn't have
revenue in 2019
a representative of the governor's
office i'm telling you literally in
quotes
told us we should have known better than
open restaurants during the
in that environment but i'm here
mostly to make sure everybody knows that
new businesses aren't really new
uh in most cases takes a year to play
years to plan in our case
we formed our llc in 2000 are you
talking about senate bill 107
oh yes i am okay
we're not there yet just uh but we'll
get you
in a moment here okay i thought it was
late actually oh yeah
no that's how you sorry well we used to
have a little thing with a number
but okay all right so uh we will close
public hearing
uh to senate bill 66
and now open up the public hearing on
senate bill
107 which you've already just got a
little inkling of
so the sponsor of senate bill 107
do i have a senate senator
okay
senator perkins quote i just promoted
her
okay i don't i don't i don't think we've
actually met yet so i'm not sure i know
how to pronounce your name
senator
here hello thank you very much uh
perkins cuoca
welcome everyone this morning thanks for
having me
um i can't really
see it as well okay so
because you've got a light right oh you
got this you don't find my video
um in the senate so i might just shut
that off since i'm in the wrong spot but
okay so thanks for having me this
morning um
for the record i'm senator rebecca
perkins quoca from senate district 21
representing the city of portsmouth in
the towns of madbury lee durham
newington newmarket in newfields i am
the prime sponsor of sb 107 relative to
financial assistance for businesses
affected by the coven 19 pandemic
the main street relief fund was designed
for main street businesses
instead many of these small local main
street businesses
lost out and it was large multinational
chain stores that received the
assistance we received from the federal
government
many local small businesses were unable
to access the main street relief fund
because of the arbitrary date imposed on
their formation
prior to may 26 2019
and a requirement to produce financial
statements from 2019
this unfortunately cut out a large
segment of new small businesses
which fill new needs in our communities
and create the most
new jobs at a time when they were really
struggling
sb 107 would ensure that newer
businesses
will be able to access any future relief
funds regardless of their date of
establishment
because the newer the business the more
critical supporting it is
these new businesses invest in their
business well before they can
open and often their opening is delayed
due to various factors beyond their
control
such as permitting financing title
concerns
supply chains or other items it's
important for us to support our newest
small businesses by directing any future
discretionary federal funding we receive
as a state
to these newest businesses
chairman thank you for the opportunity
to present sb-107
be happy to try to answer any questions
you may have i've been meeting with a
group of small business owners who
missed out on the main street relief
fund
because they were too new and i believe
many of them are on this call and will
be speaking
i also believe senator bradley is here
to speak and i would be grateful if he
could be recognized next
okay um yeah i guess just help me out
here
uh so we're you're expecting more money
is going to be
funded and and and this just doesn't say
what the parameters are just says they
should get something
is that am i reading this right that's
right chairman
so the intent um is obviously to leave
the rulemaking so to speak
to gopher because you know this is
obviously what they've
done in the past but to express the
legislative intent that we do want
these newer businesses included in any
future federal discretionary funding
that's allocated to the state yes
okay that's good does anybody have any
questions
for the center just a clerk question
yes senator could you please uh submit
your written testimony if that's
possible
absolutely i'd be happy to do that great
thank you thank you
and representative bartlett did you have
a question yes i do thank you very much
mr chair
thank you senator for coming um before
our committee um
a question that i've got is were the
um limitations to the coveted
relief funds set by the state are set by
the federal
uh federal guidelines yeah thank you
very much for the question
representative
in our case the date of may 26 2019 was
not contained in the federal
guidelines that was um imposed on the
businesses by the state
okay may i ask another question
thanks very much um i'm going to put my
insurance hat on because i was
in insurance for 35 years and one of the
issues
that businesses have after a loss is
being able to establish
what their receipts would have been
but for the loss um
what kinds of requirements
would you see that would be reasonable
to put on a newly opened business
who had not had receipts
sure and thank you again for the
thoughtful question representative
so i understand that this poses some
challenge
um and i appreciate your insurance
analyzing it
um however i do you know i do think
there are ways that we
can help these newer businesses um
show or establish you know a loss due
specifically to the pandemic
for example banks that provide you know
construction
financing or even the very lenders that
lent to these businesses
due diligence based on for example
industry standard receipts
or market research or appraisals that
help those very banks you know project
what the income streams will be for
these businesses and lending them money
and in addition i do think you know
there is industry data
from around the country that while not
um
while it may not be from that individual
business can certainly
help us help our businesses you know to
to do the diligence we need to do to
make sure that um
we can both you know exercise do care in
allocating these funds to these
businesses and yet recognize that
simply because they don't have 2019
receipts doesn't mean that they're not
a new business that adds to our
community and doesn't need our support
thanks very much thank you
okay any other questions for the senator
uh cnn okay senator bradley because i
know that's who jeb
is this is jeb bush maybe
uh good morning uh chairman hunt and
members of the committee
uh good to see all of you folks um
i just want to second the remarks of my
colleague represent
senator perkins cuoco i think she did an
excellent job
outlining the testimony that
the senate commerce committee heard from
a number
of small businesses some of whom i
believe are on
your public hearing this morning
i think one of the things that was very
compelling is
when somebody had purchased a business
that was an existing business
they were deemed to be a new business
and they did not have access
um to either main street um
funds and so it just seems to make sense
to all of us in the senate that um
[Music]
the same kind of criteria apply to these
new businesses
um that um are for
businesses that have been in existence a
little longer
especially businesses that are brand new
or
recently purchased obviously there's
going to be
a significant amount of money federal
money coming to new hampshire
i think it's very premature to say what
that money is going to be used for but
should there be something similar to
the main street relief fund or a second
version of
i think we would hope that these
businesses that were
not able to participate would be able
and that's what this bill
does so um thank you very much mr
chairman
and appreciate the opportunity to
support senate bill 107.
okay any other questions from the
committee members
thank you yeah and we're all set thank
you
uh okay so now mr clark here
now now we can hear from you
all right here let me uh
so uh as i said i'm doug clark i have a
couple of restaurants in downtown durham
um we uh we applied for the first round
of the main street relief
and uh we're told that we should have
known better than open businesses
in 2020 but they
we kind of the our story kind of fell on
deaf ears which is
that uh new businesses take years to
plan and in our case we formed llc in
we heard our general manager in 2019 and
started our payroll
we acquired our property in march of
2019 we completed our plans and got all
our approvals to the town in the spring
of 2019
began construction of our restaurant
until june of 2019
hired a chef in august of 2019 and now
we prepared all our menus and recipes in
that fall
we completed construction in march just
to find out that our equipment our
fabricator for our kitchen equipment was
rhode island
and in march rhode island shut
everything down so we weren't able to
get our equipment delivered until the
end of may
and that's all cobit related so we
weren't able to open until june of 2020.
um and so uh with that and obviously
that was a time when we had a six-foot
rule i mean the whole
uh capacity restrictions were a bit of a
problem for us because even though they
say you can do 50
if you follow the six foot rule in most
cases it's really only about 30 or 35
of capacity um for us we're uh we're
happy to have a big sidewalk so we were
able to put 11 outdoor tables
in and uh and and just to the point of
can you show an effect on your business
as most of you probably know
summer is usually the slowest time in
durham um
and uh we were doing about a hundred
thousand dollars a month when we had our
11 outdoor tables
when it started to cool down and the
students came back in our town the
residents are scared to death of the
students
and they kind of slowed down in their
willingness to kind of come downtown and
eat
so we saw our revenues go from 100 000
all three months
of the summer and the students came back
in september it went down to 80
in october went down to 60 and from
november to february it was down to 50.
so
in the middle of the winter without the
outdoor tables our business was half
of what it was in the summer and the
summer are traditionally the three
slowest months of the year in durham new
hampshire
um so and then just the other point is
independently owned businesses
to me need more help than old businesses
we have
you know we're sitting here dreamers
this is my retirement plan we put
all of our life savings into this and
then we got hit by coven uh we don't
have
years of profits in our history where we
could have built up any kind of a
foundation or a base
you know we're really struggling kind of
day to day um and even more to the point
new businesses are needed
because they're more relevant than old
businesses uh and better position to
meet the current needs of the community
in our case durham durham's downtown had
migrated from being
in the 60s it was primarily a resident
oriented business
with 90 percent of our business catered
to the residents we had family
restaurants all over the place
over the course of time it reversed and
now about 90 percent of the business
catered to the students
it's a rotating door and so the
residents to me are the most underserved
demographic
in the state of new hampshire the
residents and the adults of durham
and and people don't seem to understand
they're always more adults in durham
than students any given day of the year
and obviously they have far more
disposable income the average student
comes to town with about 1600
in their pocket which is why we have
this crazy revolving door of student
oriented businesses in downtown durham
um and so in closing i just want to
emphasize the importance
of investing in main street uh local
investment into
local businesses keep money locally
instead of the big
chains and big you know the the big
chain restaurants to me i'm sure that
more most of that money goes out of the
state when it's all said and done
and to us where the the future of um
of having economic sustainability um is
to
make sure we have a main street downtown
in every town
thanks for listening
you're on mute mr chair
sorry i keep forgetting to turn it on so
representative herbert do you have a
question
yes i do sir thank you mr hunt um
there's a whole new uh there's a 1.9
trillion dollar
uh bill i think that has been passed
and so uh is it your
anticipation that you will be able to
access
uh some of the state's money i mean some
of the federal money that's coming in
through congress into concord
uh that would be aimed at uh businesses
i mean even though the governor didn't
allow you to
uh enjoy any uh financial aid
with the last uh amount of money
what is your uh what is your opinion as
to your future
with uh that 1.9 trillion
uh of which i think 400 million dollars
of it
is expected to land uh on the governor's
pockets or desk rather i'm sorry and
just would like your opinion as to
whether or not you think you may be able
to access
some financial support
going forward
that's uh well so for us the um it's all
about this bill
i mean if the criteria doesn't change
then we again won't
qualify um and so for the state money
uh the federal restaurant recovery act
is another program
and but basically handcuffed with some
of the same restraints i do hear there's
some provision for small business
with but i haven't seen what the details
of that formula are yet
but but for the most part all of these
programs tend to disqualify
new businesses because you don't have
2019 revenue
to compare to 2020.
further question for the question
so is that no well
well obviously we're sitting here
helping we're hoping and testifying to
get uh the state to say that new
businesses would qualify for the next
round of mainstream relief we think
that's critical
rather than you know for me i um i ran
the innovation department at timberland
we
i was a new business incubator we kept
building all these new brands buying
companies and uh in the end when the um
the chairman decided to sell the company
he said let's uh get rid of our
distractions my attitude was
you can't throw the babies out with the
bathwater the babies are the future
you know the new business is the ones
that are going to pave the way that are
the most relevant and so
for the new businesses to be
disqualified from federal aid with the
old businesses and in my frustration a
lot of the old businesses got their
mainstream relief and they basically
went into hibernation and so they didn't
they didn't even maintain a payroll
during that period of time whereas
we've hired 45 people and we've kept
them on the payroll
ever since we've opened and that's our
intent is to
keep people employed and keep the
economy going as best we can
one final question uh chairman hunt sure
uh if this law if this particular piece
of legislation
passes uh would that change the
calculus for you
i believe somebody's gonna get yeah it
depends on what we get but i think
anything helps at this point i mean
we're clinging on um
but uh we're we're losing money uh we're
uh we've had to make
major adjustments with our takeout
business instead of our our
uh dine in business um we've had to
invest a lot of money in setting up
uh hepa filters and cleaning systems uh
in our
in our air conditioning systems
sanitizers masks
um outdoor tables outdoor chairs we
actually literally rebuilt the sidewalks
in front of our restaurant which cost
twenty thirty thousand dollars um but
that was how
that was the only way we were able to
kind of get through last summer and then
navigate as best we could through the
winter
thank you okay uh
thank you very much uh well now
uh patrick kennedy
kelly excuse me
okay patrick all you have to do is
unmute yourself
ah my apologies can you hear me
yes we can okay thank you chairman and
thank you for
uh all the representatives here um i
just wanted to
add my support for sb 107 give you a
little bit of background my name is
patrick kelly i'm
representing strike 9 brewing and
just a little bit of our background we
also purchased a 5 000 square foot
used to be a pharmacy in a
revitalization zone of somersworth new
hampshire
in 20 2018 we spent about a year
converting the existing building
into a brewery and brew pub so just like
the previous speaker
we went through licensing um permitting
um approvals change of use et cetera
to open strike nine in september of 2019
at the time we employed 20 employees
we were closed uh per government order
on march 16th
2020. one of the challenges that we had
is we did not develop our business model
for a takeout model this is a brew pub
for those of you who have been to brew
pub
most people like to go in and enjoy the
entertainment
um we were closed so
we temporarily closed and then reopened
in april
uh end of april 2020 uh attempting to
try the
take out model um the end result just
from
in terms of revenue is our revenue fell
even with a takeout model more than 50
percent
quarter over quarter um so to answer
uh one of the questions that came up
from representative bartlett
uh one of the things that i would
advocate for this bill
is for businesses that were open but not
for a full year
you could use a proxy in previous
quarters
to get a sense for what the receipts
were and how much of a
loss there was to businesses that were
open
less than a year um one of the things i
would say is
you know for any of the people speaking
today small business owners
nobody could really foresee the pandemic
in the risk assessment of opening a
business and it's
you know overall impact um so
uh you know my view is that for
businesses open less than a year
they're probably uh equally harmed
probably even in some cases more
financially impacted
because working capital reserves are
stressed in the first year of startup
so if you look at the first year startup
there's a lot of hiring training
essentially paying for permitting and
license fees
and really trying to get the business
open um
you know the main street fund would have
helped
um sort of get through some of the
financial challenges
uh that were had and i think uh you know
one of the positive things about this
bill is uh if it's passed
um it sort of brings uh some sort of
parity back
uh to those businesses that were in my
opinion more
severely impacted as a result of
pandemic
in being open less than a year
one other thing that i'll just note is
this came up in the senate hearing
there was a question about you know
funding
of any businesses that may not survive
and i think that's a legitimate question
uh for taxpayers and representatives um
is you know why fund a business that may
fail um
i think you know you know
businesses that are looking for any
funds should be able to provide
a profit and loss and a balance sheet
that does
that does indicate that they will
survive
this pandemic because it's you know
it's taxpayer money that's being issued
again i think small businesses have been
hurt
more so than larger businesses but they
do have to prove that they can survive
uh you know on a long-term basis
thank you for your time and um i'll take
any questions
okay uh any questions from the committee
seeing them we're all thank you and
we're all set thank you very much
thank you uh last but not least is uh
elizabeth
pumpkins good good morning let me fix my
computer
um good morning mr chairman and members
of the committee
um allow me to introduce myself i am
elizabeth tompkins and of september 2019
i became the owner of
putin on the glitz 40 market street
downtown portsmouth
um this is my fifth year here
i was employed i had two jobs to get
here and i'm here
to testify on behalf of sb 107
in favor of it because um
with the new businesses you know i think
i'm going to be
riding on the backs of what has already
been said but
we don't wake up one morning and say
tomorrow i'm going to open
it takes two to three years to get there
i worked here i was a dental hygienist
health reasons had to retire
um landed here with the previous owner
and about six months in
the conversation she approached me to
purchase the business
i set right out to score and took my
courses
how to own a business first you know how
to get your first
commercial business loan um
i then went to small business
development association i'm still
a client there and they have guided me
through all of this
when the first main street grant came up
last spring
i was like okay i don't qualify i'm kind
of new
gap we also didn't
qualify by november of 2020
i knew we weren't out of this pandemic
and heading into another winter
um you know where we do slow down
we need july august september october
through december to build up for those
quiet months
i do have record on of my first quarter
which was the last quarter of 2019
i matched what the previous owner did
and a little bit above
so the formula worked and what is that
formula i always questioned that and
with the senate
um what that is is your business model
and it takes two years to build that get
your own ducks in a row and then
negotiate
get a business valuation and now those
procedures to get
a loan are based on the previous owner's
numbers so we have those numbers um this
time there was an appeal process
but i got nowhere and i reached out to
the governor and the senators and it was
senator rebecca cloca that answered my
call literally
um so here we are now yes it would have
helped these last three months
um you know i've reduced orders there
was no computerized inventory so what
did i do during the shutdown the
mandated
shutdown last spring i came in every day
and if you can kind of see
my lovely little shopping here there's a
lot of inventory i purchased existing
inventory
i manually put that into the computer i
was hoping to get to a shopable website
thinking some funding would come in but
it's just not in the budget i caught
marketing
i use my ppp to keep four women employed
we cut hours in january and february is
to not bleed the payroll till the next
ppp comes in
um as small business owners already know
we work seven days a week
and i i can do six days a week here but
not seven
we used to have four women seven days a
week or four people
um so my first question
you know not not to be asking
rhetorically but to keep moving is you
know why may 2019 even in november of
2020.
um i had financials to go back to and
second there was no robust appeal
process there i made two typographical
errors and there were it took four weeks
to correct that and i was able to
correct them
but again it came down to the date and i
just feel like some of us
the new businesses are falling through
the cracks and to go back to
it was also said purse strings versus
heart strings
i'm a taxpayer in this state and the
country
and i would not begrudge anyone
receiving any monies
um because i'm one of those taxpayers
and new businesses are so crucial
you know i'm people were excited to see
me take over and add in
the inventory that i did um there's room
for growth
still if i don't make it you will have a
corporate hot shop and jewelry store in
town i guarantee you because they now
know there's room for it because i
found my niche i grew up from the
previous owner the previous owner was
here 15 years
she that person put this business in
yankee magazine polo magazine we're big
for derby we're big for easter we're big
for bridal
so i was affected similar to you know
event
people because people weren't going out
um
and it just would have been nice i'm not
i don't want help i don't like
asking for help but this is my sole
source of income
i put like like um mr clark said it's
it's sort of my end of life
this is what i'm going to do and i work
hard physically and
passionately i'd much rather work with
customers than be here
because this is public speaking isn't my
favorite thing
um but i just
feel that you know the young the
if i have projections for my business
that a loan officer and a business
valuation could agree to
i can also provide that for any
financial information and gladly
to do so to receive even just a little
cushion that
sits there just in case a year-long
pandemic has exhausted anybody's
resiliency plan
you think three six months okay i i did
that i didn't pay myself
last winter i haven't paid myself this
winter i'm keeping one person employed
i'm ready to bring back more
um we went curbside i do zooms for
people i do private appointments
anything i could do to
to keep the cash flow going but
my december and november were down
fifteen
thousand dollars i mean i don't i think
a lot of people don't realize what the
shop was doing
and because this is a public hearing i'm
not i'm not going to discuss that i'm
happy to provide that to the state
um so my third i have two more quick
questions
um when they're talking about what
funding is coming there's also
what could be done with plans for funds
to redistribute money that might be paid
back there are some businesses i'm
hearing that have to pay it back because
they receive grants from multiple
sources i did not
um they might have made more money
because their industry was more needed
during the pandemic so there's maybe a
way to funnel the money to us sooner i
don't know
um and i guess what i woke up in the
middle of the night in one of many
sleepless nights in this past year when
i started writing to
my governors and my senator my governor
and my senators
was if i'm not if the people testifying
here are not main street as you
label this grant money then who is
and i think some people have answered to
that and i don't begrudge the companies
who've worked hard but without a year of
revenue under my belt
i think i've done really well to make my
economic injury loan last it's supposed
to
cover the three months of closure i've
managed
to make that last so um there are people
this past weekend
people are excited that i'm still here
they're excited to get out as you know
stimulus and vaccinations but without
the foot traffic
and without the tourism anybody
in town small brick and mortar which is
the heart of portsmouth
needs some assistance and i implore you
to vote
on some sort of form of sb 107 and i
thank you from the bottom of my heart
for your time and attention
great thank you so much for coming in
anybody else
have a question for don't see any thank
you very much
and uh representative perez i apologize
i don't know how long you were there but
i
did not see you and but now i know
you're there so
you're certainly invited to testify
thank you so much
uh good morning mr shared uh good
good morning members of the committee um
my name is maria perez
i represent the 623 milford uh
today i'm testifying in support of this
bill
now more than ever i see our small
businesses in milford and
uh the towns around milford suffering
we see a lot of business going out of
business and
to be honest i see data at
the potential and the small business in
my community
um i see that uh people supporting small
businesses
um i've been going around and visiting
some of the small businesses in my town
um just to show the support um
since last year at the beginning of last
year when the pandemic started
um i went around and visited the
businesses
uh try to like bring the awareness that
um
when we supported small businesses is
like helping
our communities to grow um not just the
business itself
but we depending in the income coming in
and with depending on of the jobs of
getting created by this
small businesses so i
i will ask you every one of you to
support
this bill because i i know that the
small businesses they've gone through
a tough times but i know with the
support
of the people in the community and they
support us from us as a
state representatives in supporting this
bill we
we're going to go through this we i
believe in our communities working
together
and working together as a one team
not democrats or republicans we have to
think about this bill it's like
we supporting everyone everyone who
believe in us believe that we're here
for a reason we're here to do a job
we're here to
show that we can work together to bring
better better opportunities and better
future for our communities
thank you so much for your time it's
very nicely set
any questions from the committee members
i don't see anything
so thank you very much for coming in
thank you so much
uh last i have is uh
rashaan valerie vashon
thank you mr chair uh valerie roshan the
president
of the chamber collaborative of greater
portsmouth the chamber of commerce for
portsmouth
and good morning to you chairman hunt
and members of the committee and thank
you for allowing me to speak on this
sb107 we represent
close to 800 businesses in the greater
portsmouth area small businesses of
less than 10 employees comprise 80
percent of our membership
i'm here to testify in support of sb 107
relative to financial assistance for
businesses affected by the covet 19
pandemic
the intentions of the main street relief
fund allocated from the cares act funds
were good
and that the need for financial support
necessary to shore up our businesses was
recognized
and action taken however some of our
small businesses
some of them you've heard of from from
today who desperately needed and still
need
the financial support provided to others
have been left to fend for themselves
sb 107 proposes that entrepreneurs who
started businesses shortly before and
during the pandemic
and those who purchased pre-existing
businesses during the same period
will be eligible for federal relief
funds there's nothing more main street
as you've heard already this morning
than our locally owned small
entrepreneurial businesses who employ
our local residents
those who started businesses during this
time agonized over business plans and
financial projections
which were sufficient in most cases to
bring to the banks to get the funds for
their startups
why then would they not also be
accommodated in the main street fund
program
what if new owners who purchased
existing businesses with years of
financial data you just heard from
elizabeth
they have they have proven track records
of successful
revenue generation and net profits yet
they are also denied access to these
critical funds and yes there was an
appeals process which was difficult if
not impossible to navigate with business
owners frustrated in their attempt
to speak with a real human being
mr chairman and members of the committee
i urge you to not
not let these small businesses who are
the backbone of our community and our
economy
fall by the wayside yet again when the
new relief package
is funded by to the state so
i urge you please to vote to pass
sb 107 which allows new businesses and
new business owners
to be eligible for federal relief funds
i appreciate the opportunity to speak
with you thank you
thank you and i see uh my clerk put up
his hand so i'm sure he's going to ask
you that if you mind just
loading that up on our web page so that
we could have
your testimony i can do that thank you
uh is there any other questions from the
committee members
seeing them we thank you very much for
your testimony
uh oh there's another hand just went up
it's amazing how that works okay kevin
dwyer you want my list
oh yeah you are on my list there you are
okay
go ahead
we can see you
you're not muted right oh you're muted
you've got to unmute yourself
no he's not there anymore
can you hear me kevin you just have to
unmute yourself
or you have to read
he's there and i'm asking him to unmute
but
um right well i could see his picture
and then he went out so you wonder
whether we
have a glitchy glitchy glitchy there
look
um okay now see i see him back over he
so we dialed in again so let me promote
him back up again
okay try again
all right there you go sorry about that
um i won't take up too much time i
appreciate you guys um listening to us
all
and uh taking the time today uh i pretty
much could echo everything that doug
clark said
i uh purchased a a local thai restaurant
in portsmouth new hampshire
uh in uh june of 2019 was opened by
december of 2019
and then so i had three months of sales
before the coveted shutdown on march
16th
2020. um i guess the only additional
point i'd like to make is
uh i'm kind of in a unique situation in
portsmouth which is a
large um you know tourism accounts for a
lot of our uh
the local restaurant industry um if you
pay attention to the business that
businesses that have come and gone
since covid uh hit a year ago
a lot of them are the larger chains that
you know did employ locally but uh
that i mean like if if they're a larger
chain that
has locations from here to atlanta you
know they pretty much just look at a
balance sheet and then
uh trim the fad for whichever store so
you know wasn't the producer for them so
i don't think
the the larger restaurant groups have as
much of a concern for the local economy
as a local
young business owner like myself i
employ
everybody lives in the greater
portsmouth area that i employ
and uh and i don't have like an
allegiance i guess to um
anywhere foreign it's just um it's i'm
from portsmouth and i
want to stay in portsmouth and my
business is in portsmouth
so i guess if you pay attention to who's
coming in
to the town uh since all of this it's a
lot of larger restaurant groups that
uh you know could foreseeably do the
same thing they're not from here and if
uh if it didn't work out they're they're
not as invested in the community
uh and then you know they looked at my
spot before i opened and
i know that they've looked at my spot as
coven's hit
so um it's you know this bill would help
protect
uh local i mean it is called main street
uh a main street business that
and i'm 29 years old and i would like to
keep grow this business
for the next several decades and
continue to
be a integral part of my community's
economy
that's all thank you all right thank you
okay uh i don't see any questions
any more people who want to speak
uh i guess we're all set so we had
68 people in support no opposition
nobody neutral and with that i will
close the public
hearing on senate bill 107
and i think that's it for the day
so we will pick this up again tomorrow
morning at
nine o'clock see you all and all have a
wonderful afternoon we've got this one
right here at noon boy
there's a lot of marvel all right at
noon
and uh very very briefly mr chairman
we there will be a commerce room set up
in the lob tomorrow
in 201 203 just
for those who want to attend in person
okay
thank you sure okay
yeah all right for those who who are
there sort of
you're there in the room okay thank you
all